Welcome back to the second drink of Dunder Mifflin Infinity, part one. We wanted to start with some fan mail that you all sent in for this episode. And by the way, you probably sent this in maybe four, maybe five years ago. Because we're going back to the old archives for all of our episodes as we do our second drinks. Yeah. And we found a great background catch by Angel R in Fort Worth. So, Angela, you remember how this episode starts with the cold open of Jim and Pam in the break room. Mm-hmm. Yeah, yeah, right. Jim gets Pam a soda and then he's looking at some potato chips and then Pam gives him a smooch on the cheek. And of course, poor Toby is watching this whole exchange. Yes. All right. Well, here is Angel's background catch for that cold open. Angel said, quote, ladies, at 46 seconds, Michael asked Toby about the letter he sent out to everyone saying people are complaining about PDA in the office. The clock on the wall behind Toby.
欢迎回到《办公室》第二轮重温系列，今天我们讨论的是《邓德·米夫林无限公司》第一部分。我们想先从你们为这一集寄来的粉丝来信开始。顺便说一下，你们可能是在四五年前寄来的，因为我们在做第二轮重温时，会翻看所有剧集的旧档案。没错，我们在沃斯堡的Angel R发来的邮件中发现了一个很棒的背景细节。安吉拉，你还记得这一集开头是吉姆和帕姆在休息室的冷开场吗？嗯，记得，没错。吉姆给帕姆拿了苏打水，然后他在看薯片，接着帕姆亲了他的脸颊。当然，可怜的托比目睹了这一切。是的。好了，这就是Angel关于那个冷开场的背景发现。Angel写道：“女士们，在46秒时，迈克尔问托比关于他发给每个人的信，说有人抱怨办公室里的公开亲热行为（PDA）。托比身后的墙上挂着时钟。”
he says it's around 9.15 a.m. So that means Pam kissed Jim in the break room earlier than that. That's pretty early for a breakroom snack. Also, how quickly did Toby write that PDA letter? Please discuss. That is really early. So what? He's getting a soda and potato chips like early in the morning? Right away. And then Toby witnesses this and he just bangs out a letter, I guess. I don't know. I'm concerned about Jim's early morning. snacks now. Well, I love that catch. And we also got a fan mail flurry for this episode. Many, many people wrote in about it. I haven't told you about it, Jenna, because I wanted to surprise you. What is it? Mm-hmm. I'm just going to enjoy this a minute. I'm going to enjoy it.
他说时间大约是上午9点15分。所以这意味着帕姆在休息室亲吻吉姆的时间比那还要早。对于休息室的零食时间来说，这太早了。另外，托比写那封PDA信的速度有多快？请讨论一下。那确实太早了。所以怎么回事？他一大早就在拿苏打水和薯片吗？立刻就拿了。然后托比目睹了这一切，我想他大概是立刻就写了那封信。我不知道。我现在很担心吉姆的早间零食。好吧，我喜欢这个发现。我们还收到了很多关于这一集的粉丝来信。很多人都写信提到了这件事。珍娜，我还没告诉你，因为我想给你个惊喜。是什么？嗯，我要先享受一下这一刻。我要享受它。
The fan mail flurry is about the word feral. Do you remember we talked about feral cats and you said, say it, feral, feral. All right, we got a fan mail flurry. Holly M. says, Sorry, Jenna, but your feral doesn't exist. Angela wins this one. Another person, Nola M. wrote in and said, Hey, Jenna, it's definitely feral, but I was with you on Chuck versus Chunk. Another person, Monica G. wrote in and said, It's feral.
粉丝来信狂潮是关于“feral”（野生的）这个词。你还记得我们讨论过野猫，你说，读一下，feral，feral。好吧，我们收到了粉丝来信狂潮。Holly M说：“抱歉，珍娜，但你的‘feral’根本不存在。安吉拉赢了。”另一个人，Nola M写道：“嘿，珍娜，绝对是feral，但我支持你关于Chuck和Chunk的争论。”另一个人，Monica G写道：“是feral。”
Angela Kinsey is right, Jenna. Kayla M. wrote in and said, I'm with Angela Kinsey and the rest of the English-speaking world on the pronunciation of feral. Eileen G said as someone who works in TNR with feral cats Angela is correct on the pronunciation. Lady, I felt very seen. This is my Chuck moment
安吉拉·金赛是对的，珍娜。Kayla M写道：“我支持安吉拉·金赛和世界上其他讲英语的人，关于feral的发音。”Eileen G说：“作为一个从事TNR（捕捉、绝育、放归）野猫工作的人，安吉拉的发音是正确的。”女士，我感觉被大家看到了。这就是我的“Chunk”时刻。
when everyone came after me for chunk it. Farrell. All right, while you were reading that, I did Google it. And I stand corrected. Thank you. It is pronounced. How do you say it?
当时每个人都因为“chunk”来攻击我。Ferall。好吧，在你读的时候，我确实谷歌了一下。我收回我的话。谢谢。它是这样发音的。你怎么读？
Farrell. Ferrell. A feral, a feral cat. There it is. Not a feral cat. Not a feral cat. Oh, you have to put a bunch of English on it, ladies. Ferral cat.
Farrell。Ferrell。一只feral，一只feral猫。就是这样。不是一只feral猫。不是一只feral猫。哦，你们得加点英式口音，女士们。Ferral猫。
Thank you to everyone who wrote in about that. I really enjoyed it. All right. Well, here's another one. Emily M. wrote in to say that she loves our location breakdowns and enjoyed hearing about where we filmed the lake scenes for this episode. And she thinks we need to do a special episode called Scranton locations. And we should record it from Scranton as we visit all of the iconic office locations.
谢谢所有写信来讨论这件事的人。我真的很喜欢。好吧，还有一封。Emily M写信说她喜欢我们的外景解析，也很喜欢听我们讲述这一集湖边场景是在哪里拍摄的。她认为我们应该做一个特别节目叫“斯克兰顿外景地”。我们应该在访问所有标志性的办公室地点时，从斯克兰顿进行录制。
What do you think, Angela? I think my calendar in 2026 is pretty open. Oh, okay. Let's go to Scranton. And do an episode called Scranton locations. All right. Thank you for the idea, Emily M. All right, Lola G from Brooklyn wanted to know if there were any fun candy bag alts for this episode.
你觉得呢，安吉拉？我觉得我2026年的日程表挺空的。哦，好吧。那我们就去斯克兰顿，做一期叫“斯克兰顿外景地”的节目。好的，谢谢你的建议，Emily M。好吧，布鲁克林的Lola G想知道这一集有没有什么有趣的糖果袋备选台词。
Well, Lola, I went digging, and here's what I found. Remember that famous Angela talking head where she says, quote, I'm not surprised Pam is the office mattress? Well, there were two candy bag alts for that, and I want to share them with you. Okay. The first one is Angela throwing some sass at Jim. Ready? Okay. The purse girl, Karen, now Pam, note to Jim, the zipper goes up as well.
嗯，Lola，我去翻了翻，这是我找到的。还记得那个著名的安吉拉访谈片段吗？她说：“我不惊讶帕姆是办公室的公共汽车。”嗯，那段话有两个糖果袋备选台词，我想和你们分享一下。好的。第一个是安吉拉对吉姆的讽刺。准备好了吗？好的。“那个包包女孩，凯伦，现在是帕姆，给吉姆提个醒，拉链也是要拉上的。”
The next one is Angela throwing shade. at Pam. It was a must shoot along with the Pam office mattress one. Okay. Okay, here it is. Quote, I share very private things with Pam. And as it turns out, Pam tells me nothing. I think she's repressed. Oh, okay. That might be the pot calling the kettle. But yeah, those are some fun candy bag alts. Thanks, Lola, for writing in. Well, Angela, I have one more that I wanted to share. It's a little tidbit from Timothy and Eugene Oregon. He wrote in to say, I remember going on the Dunder Mifflin Infinity website, so I was excited to hear you talk about it. There were a few games you could play. Did you know there was one where you could dress Creed? What do you mean? Like dress them how?
下一个是安吉拉对帕姆的挖苦。这是和“帕姆是办公室公共汽车”那段一起拍摄的。好的。好的，在这里。引用：“我和帕姆分享非常私人的事情。结果呢，帕姆什么都不告诉我。我觉得她压抑了。”哦，好吧。这可能是五十步笑百步。但确实，这些是一些有趣的糖果袋备选台词。谢谢Lola的来信。好吧，安吉拉，我还有一个想分享。这是来自俄勒冈州尤金市的Timothy发来的小贴士。他写道：“我记得我上过‘邓德·米夫林无限公司’的网站，所以我很兴奋听到你们谈论它。里面有几个游戏可以玩。你知道有一个游戏可以给克里德换装吗？”你是什么意思？比如怎么换装？
Yes, it was. I went to the link that Joya sent us. Uh-huh. It was like a paper doll game. And it was called Make Creed Young again. And you could dress Creed in various clothes and hairstiles and accessories to try to make him look younger so he could keep his job. Amazing. Amazing. Well, thank you all for writing in. I enjoyed those letters. So did I.
是的，确实有。我去了Joya发给我们的链接。嗯哼。那就像一个纸娃娃游戏。它叫“让克里德重返青春”。你可以给克里德穿上各种衣服、发型和配饰，试图让他看起来更年轻，这样他就能保住工作。太棒了。太棒了。好吧，谢谢大家的来信。我很喜欢这些信。我也是。
Before we get to the episode, I would like to give a plug to the musical Sufts, which is now touring the U.S. My friend Michelle Cashman is one of the producers, and I saw it when it was on Broadway. It is fantastic. It's an original musical that tells the story of all of the just brilliant, passionate funny American women who fought tirelessly for the right to vote. I took my daughter, she's 11, she loved it. She actually went back to see it with some of her other school friends. And this summer, when she was doing debate camp, she had to pick an influential American figure to debate.
在进入这一集之前，我想为音乐剧《Suffs》做个宣传，它现在正在美国巡演。我的朋友Michelle Cashman是制片人之一，我在百老汇看过它。它太棒了。这是一部原创音乐剧，讲述了所有那些为争取投票权而不懈奋斗的杰出、热情、有趣的美国女性的故事。我带我女儿去了，她11岁，她很喜欢。她甚至和学校的朋友又回去看了一次。今年夏天，当她参加辩论营时，她必须选择一个有影响力的美国人物进行辩论。
She had to say, who is someone in history who was very influential and important? And she picked suffragist Alice Paul. And I said, oh, how did you learn about Alice Paul? Like, she just picked this name out of, you know, just off the top of her head. And she said, Mom, from the musical Suffs. Aw. So the musical is both educational and entertaining. The music is great.
她必须说，历史上谁是非常有影响力且重要的人？她选择了女性参政权论者爱丽丝·保罗。我说，哦，你是怎么知道爱丽丝·保罗的？就像，她随口就说出了这个名字。她说：“妈妈，是从音乐剧《Suffs》里知道的。”噢。所以这部音乐剧既有教育意义又很有趣。音乐很棒。
It won two Tony Awards for Best Book and Best Score. And it's great for the whole family. It starts running in L.A. on November 18th, but it's moving all across the country. It's going to be in Philadelphia, Hartford, Charlotte, Dayton, Detroit, Lincoln, Rochester, Washington, D.C., and Chicago, you know, my new favorite city, just to name a few. But I want to shout it out because I love supporting theater, and I'm really proud of my friend for championing this to the stage. That's fantastic. We'll all have to check it out. All right, everybody who wrote in, I always love the little nuggets of trivia.
它获得了两项托尼奖，分别是最佳剧本和最佳配乐。它非常适合全家观看。它将于11月18日在洛杉矶开演，但它会去全国各地。它会去费城、哈特福德、夏洛特、代顿、底特律、林肯、罗切斯特、华盛顿特区和芝加哥，你知道的，我最喜欢的新城市，这只是其中几个。但我一定要提一下，因为我喜欢支持戏剧，而且我为我的朋友能把这部剧搬上舞台感到非常自豪。太棒了。我们都得去看看。好吧，所有写信的人，我总是喜欢这些小小的琐事。
We unlock together. and now please enjoy our second drink of Dunder Mifflin Infinity Part 1. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you.
我们一起解锁。现在，请欣赏我们的《邓德·米夫林无限公司》第一部分第二轮重温。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你们制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会解析一集《办公室》，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你们的独家幕后故事。
We're the office ladies. Hello, Pam Sass. I'm wearing my PAMSass shirt, and I'm loving it. It is so stinking, cute. I can't wait to get mine. They're really cute, and they're a conversation starter because I parked in the parking lot here at Airwolf, and as I was walking in, a guy, by the way, it was 10.50 a.m. A guy had a cocktail in his hand and said, what party you go?
我们是办公室女士。你好，帕姆的讽刺。我穿着我的“帕姆讽刺”衬衫，我爱死它了。它真是太可爱了。我等不及要拿到我的了。它们真的很可爱，而且是开启对话的好话题，因为我把车停在Airwolf的停车场，当我走进去时，一个家伙，顺便说一下，当时是上午10点50分。一个手里拿着鸡尾酒的家伙说，你要去参加什么派对？
going to. Okay. I was like, he was in fluorescent yellow shorts with a white t-shirt. And I was like, um, I'm, what? Is it because of my, is it because of my Pamstash shirt? You think I'm going to a party? I'm pretty sure. It had absolutely nothing to do with your shirt that you could have been dressed in literally
好吧。我说，他穿着荧光黄短裤和白色T恤。我说，嗯，我，什么？是因为我的“帕姆讽刺”衬衫吗？你以为我要去参加派对？我很确定。这和你穿的衬衫完全没关系，你当时穿什么都一样。
anything. This is 100% about him and his shorts and his cocktail before 11. Yeah. Well, he's doing it. All right. Today is Dunder Mifflin Infinity Part 1. This is Season 4 episode 3. This is another one of our one-hour shows that was meant to kick off season 4.
这百分之百是他和他那条短裤，还有他在11点前喝的鸡尾酒的问题。是的。好吧，他确实在这么做。好了。今天是《邓德·米夫林无限公司》第一部分。这是第四季第三集。这是我们另一集一小时长的剧集，原本是为了开启第四季。
We're dividing it into two parts. This episode was written by Michael Schur, and it was directed by Craig Zisk. Yes. All right, Jenna, you're up. It's summary time. Here is a summary of what we are coming. covering today. When Ryan tries to implement new ideas, like issuing everyone a Blackberry and announcing the new Dunder Mifflin Infinity website, Michael feels he may be a victim of ageism.
我们把它分成了两部分。这一集由迈克尔·舒尔编剧，克雷格·齐斯克执导。是的。好了，珍娜，轮到你了。总结时间到了。这是我们今天要涵盖的内容总结。当瑞安试图实施新想法时，比如给每个人发黑莓手机，并宣布新的“邓德·米夫林无限公司”网站，迈克尔觉得他可能成了年龄歧视的受害者。
Jim and Pam's relationship goes public and they are now forced to face the scrutiny of the entire staff. Meanwhile, Angela is going to give Dwight one more chance after his mercy killing of sprinkles. Yep. All right. Fast fact number one, like I said, this episode was directed by Craig Zisk. He had been an executive producer on Weeds, the United States of Tara, and the Larry Sanders show, and more recently, Brooklyn Nine Nine, he's directed a ton of television. He directed a bunch of episodes of Scrubs and movies. Do you remember Craig?
吉姆和帕姆的关系公开了，他们现在被迫面对全体员工的审视。与此同时，安吉拉在德怀特对斯普林克尔斯实施安乐死后，决定再给他一次机会。是的。好了，第一个速记事实，就像我说的，这一集是由克雷格·齐斯克执导的。他曾是《单身毒妈》、《塔拉合众国》和《拉里·桑德斯秀》的执行制片人，最近还执导了《神烦警探》，他执导过大量的电视节目。他执导过很多集《实习医生风云》和电影。你还记得克雷格吗？
I do remember Craig. And actually, when Craig came to direct, we had a little thing in common, which is I had worked with his brother, Randy Zisk, who's also a producer and director, and he had directed me on my episode of Monk. So when I saw Craig, we had, we sort of like had this moment. He was like, hey, you were on my brother's show. And I was like, yes, how are you? Well, I had a little thing not in common with Craig, but in adoration of him. Because when he was 25 years old, he was one of the producers of the television show cop rock. Do you remember cop rock, Angela? No, I've never heard of it. Oh my God. What? Oh my God. Okay. It came out in 1990. Okay. It was on ABC. It was,
我记得克雷格。事实上，当克雷格来执导时，我们有一个共同点，那就是我曾与他的兄弟兰迪·齐斯克合作过，他也是制片人和导演，他曾在我出演的那集《神探阿蒙》中执导过我。所以当我看到克雷格时，我们有一种共鸣。他说：“嘿，你出演过我兄弟的剧。”我说：“是的，你好吗？”好吧，我和克雷格没有共同点，但我很崇拜他。因为当他25岁时，他是电视节目《Cop Rock》的制片人之一。你还记得《Cop Rock》吗，安吉拉？不，我从没听说过。天哪。什么？天哪。好吧。它是在1990年播出的。好吧。它在ABC播出。它，
brace yourself, a musical comedy drama show about the LAPD. Oh my gosh. There's so much happening. Okay. It was created by Stephen Botchko, who had also created the very famous Hill Street Blues. And basically, Angela, it was a cop show. Like maybe imagine law and order if all of a sudden in the middle of the episode, they break into song. No. Yep. No. I can't do it. Here is an audio clip from an episode. You know, when they all gather in the room and like the lieutenant is like, here's what's on the. the docket today. We got this happening and this happening. Yeah. Yeah. Okay, that's what he's doing at the top of this scene. Sam, will you play the clip? Item last, on the teletype, we still got the Franklin Avenue flashers. Okay, that's it. And hey, hey, let's be careful out there. Let's be careful out there.
做好心理准备，是一部关于洛杉矶警察局的音乐喜剧剧情片。天哪。发生了太多事了。好吧。它是由斯蒂芬·博奇科创作的，他也创作了非常著名的《希尔街的布鲁斯》。基本上，安吉拉，它是一部警察剧。就像想象一下《法律与秩序》，如果突然在剧集中间，他们开始唱歌。不。是的。不。我做不到。这是一集里的音频片段。你知道，当他们都聚集在房间里，中尉说：“这是今天的日程表。我们有这个和那个发生。”是的。是的。好吧，这就是他在这一幕开头做的事。萨姆，你能播放那个片段吗？最后一项，在电传打字机上，我们还有富兰克林大道的露体狂。好吧，就是这样。嘿，嘿，大家小心点。大家小心点。
We had a 187 at the 7-Eleven on the corner of 4th and Maine. No, they did not. They did. No, they didn't. It was canceled after 11 episodes. Oh, why? TV Guide ranked it number eight on its list of the 50. worst TV shows of all time in 2002.
我们在第四街和缅因街拐角的7-11发生了一起187（谋杀案）。不，他们没有。他们有。不，他们没有。它在播出11集后被取消了。《电视指南》在2002年将其列为史上50部最差电视节目榜单的第八名。
Wow. But it actually won two Emmy Awards for editing and outstanding achievement in music and lyrics. I want you to know I loved this show. I watched every episode. This is all we need to know about you, Jenna. It was like glee, but a cop show. It was brilliant. You can find it on YouTube.
哇。但它实际上获得了两项艾美奖，分别是剪辑和音乐歌词杰出成就奖。我想让你知道我喜欢这个节目。我看了每一集。这就是我们需要了解的关于你的一切，珍娜。它就像《欢乐合唱团》，但是一部警察剧。它太棒了。你可以在YouTube上找到它。
It sounds like an S&L parody of like a cop show or something. That is amazing. I now have to go see just one. I mean, I mean, I have to see one where they're like, we got the perp in the cell, we're going to frisk him now. I think that's a song. I got the perp, frisk him up. Ooh, frisk him up.
听起来像是《周六夜现场》对警察剧的恶搞之类的。这太神奇了。我现在必须去看一集。我的意思是，我必须看一集他们说：“我们把罪犯关在牢房里，现在我们要搜他的身。”我觉得那是一首歌。我抓住了罪犯，搜他的身。噢，搜他的身。
That's a good one. Frisk him up, frisk him up, frisk him up, frisk him down. What did you find? Is there a gun? Is there a knife? Are you just happy to see me? The show really writes itself. Oh, my gosh.
那是个好段子。搜他的身，搜他的身，搜他的身，搜他的身。你发现了什么？有枪吗？有刀吗？你只是很高兴见到我吗？这节目简直是自写剧本。天哪。
Wow. I want you to be safe out there. You heard him. Be safe. Out there. Be safe. This is now like a hybrid West Side story. Coprock.
哇。我希望你在外面注意安全。你听到他说的了。注意安全。在外面。注意安全。这现在就像一部混合了《西区故事》的《Cop Rock》。
That's all I could picture in my mind. Oh, my Lord. Okay. That's amazing. And Craig worked on it. He was one of the producers. Well, I'll bring us back with Fast Fact number two. Okay.
我脑子里只能想到这个。噢，天哪。好吧。这太神奇了。而且克雷格参与了制作。他是制片人之一。好吧，我带大家回到第二个速记事实。好的。
This episode. episode, Dunder Mifflin Infinity, aired in October of 2007, and also in October 2007 was a big office convention in Scranton, Pennsylvania. Yes, and a whole bunch of us went, a huge group. I mean, it was like Greg went and Mike Scher and Jen Salado, a bunch of the writers and the cast. I think the whole entire cast was there, except for you and Steve, right? And John, everyone else went like the whole shebang. I was not allowed to go because remember I shared last week about how I broke my back. Yeah. I was not cleared for plane travel at this time. I was I was super sad you weren't there. I found some emails where we traded emails. You're like, please tell everyone I
这一集，《邓德·米夫林无限公司》，于2007年10月播出，2007年10月也是在宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿举行的一次大型《办公室》大会。是的，我们很多人都去了，一大群人。我的意思是，格雷格去了，迈克·舒尔和珍·萨拉多，还有很多编剧和演员。我想整个剧组都在那里，除了你和史蒂夫，对吧？还有约翰，其他人都去了，就像整个大部队。我不被允许去，因为记得我上周分享过我怎么摔断了背吗？是的。我当时没有被批准进行飞机旅行。我超级难过你没去。我发现了一些我们交换过的邮件。你说：“请告诉大家我
said hi. But it was a absolute blast. Scranton was so much fun. Scranton. Everyone there was great. And then me and Craig and Brian went on the Today Show with Al Roker. Al Roker came to Scranton. And we did the Today Show from there with him. And I mean, it was just a blast. I was so jealous. That looked like so much fun. You guys did like a whole Q&A panel and like a meet and greet, right?
问好。”但这绝对是一次狂欢。斯克兰顿太有趣了。斯克兰顿。那里的每个人都很棒。然后我和克雷格还有布莱恩和阿尔·罗克一起上了《今日秀》。阿尔·罗克来到了斯克兰顿。我们和他一起在那里做了《今日秀》。我的意思是，这简直太棒了。我太嫉妒了。那看起来太有趣了。你们做了像整个问答小组和见面会之类的，对吧？
And we did like a concert. Like there was a concert and a bunch of people from the office performed like Craig and Malora. Like everyone got up on stage. was so much fun. But, you know, lady, this was something you and I both share because I was able to go to this convention. But then at the end of the show, there was another one, like a big rap party convention. And it was my daughter's birthday. So you went to that one. So I found all these emails, Jenna, where we sort of bookend this experience for each other because I went to one and you got to go to the other. Yeah. I remember that. I was so glad I got to go to that one at the
我们还办了一场音乐会。就像有一场音乐会，很多《办公室》的人都表演了，比如克雷格和梅洛拉。每个人都上了台。太有趣了。但是，你知道，女士，这是你我共同经历的事情，因为我能去参加这次大会。但在剧集结束时，还有另一场，就像大型杀青派对大会。那是我女儿的生日。所以你去了那一场。所以我找到了所有这些邮件，珍娜，我们以某种方式为彼此书写了这段经历的结尾，因为我去了其中一场，而你去了另一场。是的。我记得。我很高兴我能去剧集结束时的那一场。
end of the show. Because I couldn't, I couldn't, like, leave the experience of the office having never visited Scranton. I know. I just remember I was really jealous that you got to go and I was bummed that I had to stay home. But, you know, well, you know, we've never gotten to go together. And that's on my bucket list. When this podcast is done, I want you and I to go to Scranton. That's on my wish list. I want you and I to go to Scranton and just anonymously sign up for the office tour. And just show up and be like, take us on the tour. Yes, to all the spots. I want to do it. Well, listen, there was something else going on during this time. I don't know if you remember, but we were on the cover of Entertainment Weekly Magazine. We were? It came out October 5th,
因为我不能，我不能，就像，离开《办公室》的经历却从未访问过斯克兰顿。我知道。我只是记得我很嫉妒你能去，而我很沮丧我必须待在家里。但是，你知道，好吧，你知道，我们从来没有一起去过。这在我的遗愿清单上。当这个播客结束时，我希望你和我一起去斯克兰顿。这在我的愿望清单上。我希望你和我一起去斯克兰顿，然后匿名报名参加《办公室》之旅。然后直接出现，说：“带我们去参观吧。”是的，去所有的地方。我想做这件事。好吧，听着，当时还有别的事情发生。我不知道你是否记得，但我们上了《娱乐周刊》杂志的封面。我们上了吗？它在10月5日出版，
which was the day after this episode aired. And there were a few sets of couples. Steve and Malora as Jan and Michael were on one cover and then Angela and Dwight were on one and Jim and Pam and then Ryan and Kelly so you could pick which issue had the cover but then we were all on the inside in this big group photo I remember doing that photo shoot I know it was so fun it was such a such a cool day and I couldn't believe it like I had always you know picked up entertainment weekly I love television it was like my dream to be on TV and then to all of a sudden be on the cover and be in it with you guys I couldn't even believe it. I have one framed. Well, this is what was happening at this time, which was that the show was truly blowing up. And we were on covers of magazines. And it was so surreal. Early on,
也就是这一集播出后的第二天。有几对情侣。史蒂夫和梅洛拉作为简和迈克尔上了一个封面，然后安吉拉和德怀特上了一个，吉姆和帕姆，还有瑞安和凯利，所以你可以选择哪一期作为封面，但我们都在内页的一张大合影里。我记得拍那张照片。我知道，太有趣了，真是太酷的一天了。我简直不敢相信，就像我一直（你知道）买《娱乐周刊》，我热爱电视，能上电视是我的梦想，然后突然上了封面，还和你们在一起，我简直不敢相信。我装裱了一张。好吧，这就是当时发生的事情，那就是这部剧真的火了。我们上了杂志封面。这太超现实了。早期，
I tried to save every single mention of us or the show from any publication because it just felt so fleeting and then at this time it became it became impossible it was just constant and we were really out in the zeitgeist is that the right word yeah yeah no the show was just really catching on i'll tell you what between my mom and my grandmother and my cousin carol and my aunt brenda i think i have everything we were ever mentioned in because he saved everything and they would send it to me Well, speaking of being out in the world in a big way, fast fact number three, we got a lot of fan mail from people about the Dunder Mifflin Infinity website. And they wanted to know if it was real. Well, it was real and it went out into the world around this exact same time as this episode.
我试图保存每一篇关于我们或这部剧的报道，因为这感觉太短暂了，然后在这个时候，它变得不可能了，这简直是持续不断的，我们真的处于时代精神之中，这个词对吗？是的，是的，不，这部剧真的火了。我告诉你，在我妈妈、我祖母、我表姐卡罗尔和我阿姨布伦达之间，我想我保存了所有提到我们的东西，因为他保存了一切，他们会寄给我。好吧，说到在世界上产生巨大影响，第三个速记事实，我们收到了很多粉丝关于“邓德·米夫林无限公司”网站的来信。他们想知道它是否是真的。好吧，它是真的，而且它就在这一集播出的同一时间出现在世界上。
That is right. And we reached out to Joya Balfour. Joya, as you remember, Jenna, was part of the team. team at NBC.com. And you guys, networks were not doing digital content during this time. It's just something they didn't do. So NBC was really on the forefront. And I talked to Joya, and she was saying they were trying to find ways to sustain the fandom to keep fans engaged. And one of the things they did was they launched dundermifflin Infinity.com. You could go on and play these games. There were virtual branches that fans could join. They could perform tasks where they would earn
没错。我们联系了Joya Balfour。Joya，正如你记得的，珍娜，是NBC.com团队的一员。你们知道，当时网络并没有在做数字内容。这只是他们不做的事情。所以NBC真的走在了前沿。我和Joya谈过，她说他们正在寻找维持粉丝群的方法，以保持粉丝的参与度。他们做的事情之一就是推出了DunderMifflinInfinity.com。你可以上去玩这些游戏。有粉丝可以加入的虚拟分部。他们可以执行任务，赚取
shrewpucks and then they could spend their shrewd bucks on virtual items in sort of like the office and they went around to all of our desks they took pictures of the set so that they could actually buy virtual items and this site ran for three years on nbc.com and fans got signed items from the show and also if they submitted their artwork it would be displayed in episodes jenna fan art was put around the set. So your art might make it into the show. It might end up on the refrigerator in the kitchen or on a bulletin board like by Creed and Meredith. And fans could look for their art if they won. Is that amazing? It's really incredible because I just want to remind everyone, there was no Instagram. There were no apps back then. Like this was really, really revolutionary in terms of
“Shrewbucks”（精明币），然后他们可以用这些精明币在办公室里购买虚拟物品，他们去了我们所有的办公桌，拍了场景的照片，这样他们就可以购买虚拟物品，这个网站在NBC.com上运行了三年，粉丝们得到了剧组的签名物品，而且如果他们提交了艺术作品，它还会显示在剧集中。珍娜，粉丝艺术被放在了场景周围。所以你的艺术作品可能会出现在剧中。它可能会出现在厨房的冰箱上，或者像克里德和梅雷迪思旁边的公告栏上。如果粉丝赢了，他们可以寻找他们的艺术作品。这不神奇吗？这真的很不可思议，因为我只是想提醒大家，当时没有Instagram。那时没有应用程序。这在
that idea of fan engagement and getting to participate in some way actively with your favorite show. Yes, and they even made a video, and actually I have audio of it. Sam, can you play the video of Dunder Mifflin Infinity.com? Do you like paper? Well, we like you. Dunder Mifflin is looking for bright, energetic paper people to open up their own branch and become part of the Dunder Mifflin family. Interested in your own future, go to Dunder Mifflin Infinity.com to find out more. I love it. Isn't that great? And I asked Joya who did that voiceover, and she said, that's just a voiceover actor that they hired. She has a whole page on her website, Joya Balfour.com, where you can look at Dundermifflin Infinity and what all they did with it. You can actually watch that video that we just played for you. And I told Joya, over the next few episodes, the next few seasons, I'm going to reach out
粉丝参与和以某种方式积极参与你最喜欢的节目方面，真的是非常非常革命性的。是的，他们甚至制作了一个视频，实际上我有它的音频。萨姆，你能播放DunderMifflinInfinity.com的视频吗？你喜欢纸吗？好吧，我们喜欢你。邓德·米夫林正在寻找聪明、精力充沛的“纸人”来开设他们自己的分部，并成为邓德·米夫林大家庭的一员。对你的未来感兴趣吗？去DunderMifflinInfinity.com了解更多。我喜欢它。这不棒吗？我问Joya是谁做的配音，她说，那只是他们雇佣的配音演员。她在她的网站JoyaBalfour.com上有一个完整的页面，你可以在那里查看“邓德·米夫林无限公司”以及他们用它做了什么。你实际上可以观看我们刚才为你播放的那个视频。我告诉Joya，在接下来的几集，接下来的几季里，我要联系
to her, kind of like your Kentopedia, because I really started becoming a more active participant on NBC.com. I did a thing called Adventures with Angela. We had the accountant's webisodes. There were a lot more fun things we started to do. And I'm going to hit her up along the way. I love that. They should relaunch this. They should relaunch Dunder Mifflin Infinity as an app.
她，有点像你的“Kentopedia”，因为我真的开始成为NBC.com上更积极的参与者。我做了一个叫“安吉拉的冒险”的节目。我们有会计的网络剧集。我们开始做更多有趣的事情了。我会一路联系她。我喜欢这个。他们应该重新推出这个。他们应该把“邓德·米夫林无限公司”重新推出为一个应用程序。
I know. And you can do all these same things. Someone, Joya, I don't know. Who does this? Peacock. Get on it. Peacock. Are you listening?
我知道。你可以做所有这些同样的事情。有人，Joya，我不知道。谁做这个？Peacock。行动起来。Peacock。你们在听吗？
Do this. Yeah. Well, lady, listen, I think we should take a break. Those were incredible fast facts. We are killing it today and giving us compliments. But let's take a break and then we'll come back in and get into this episode. Okay, great, because I've got more details, lady. More details.
做这件事。是的。好吧，女士，听着，我觉得我们应该休息一下。那些是令人难以置信的速记事实。我们今天表现得太棒了，还给了我们赞美。但让我们休息一下，然后回来进入这一集。好的，太棒了，因为我有更多细节，女士。更多细节。
I know I'm not Kintapedia, but maybe I'm Kinsipedia on this one. Kinsipedia after the break. Kinspedia. man host of the preamble. Listen, I know you're dealing with a lot and it's even harder to do it when the world around you feels chaotic. But I'm here to help. Each week, my expert guests and I slow things down to talk about the stories shaping our world. What's really happening behind the headlines, why it matters, how it all connects. And if you're ready for real understanding and maybe even a little bit of hope, follow and listen to the preamble wherever you get your podcasts.
我知道我不是“Kintapedia”，但也许我是这次的“Kinsipedia”。休息后就是“Kinspedia”。我是《序言》的主持人。听着，我知道你正在处理很多事情，当周围的世界让你感到混乱时，这更难做到。但我在这里提供帮助。每周，我和我的专家嘉宾都会放慢节奏，讨论塑造我们世界的那些故事。头条新闻背后到底发生了什么，为什么它很重要，这一切是如何联系在一起的。如果你准备好真正理解，甚至可能有一点希望，请在任何你获取播客的地方关注并收听《序言》。
All right, we are back, and we open this episode in the break room where there is no more heartbreak. In fact, there is flirty flirt cuteness in there. In fact, I'm pretty sure it's now called the flirt room. I think you're right. Jim and Pam. Pam has already gotten Jim a soda. Mm-hmm. Because she knows what he likes because she's his girlfriend.
好吧，我们回来了，我们在休息室开启了这一集，那里不再有心碎。事实上，那里有调情般的可爱。事实上，我很确定它现在被称为“调情室”。我想你是对的。吉姆和帕姆。帕姆已经给吉姆拿了苏打水。嗯哼。因为她知道他喜欢什么，因为她是他的女朋友。
And then she gives him a little peck, a little kiss as she's leaving. But Toby sees. Can we talk about Paul's expression? We can. I froze on his face. I was laughing so hard. I don't even know what all it's conveying. It's conveying so many things at 20 seconds, Toby's face.
然后她离开时给了他一个小啄，一个小吻。但托比看到了。我们能谈谈保罗的表情吗？我们可以。我定格在他的脸上。我笑得太厉害了。我甚至不知道它传达了什么。在20秒时，托比的脸传达了太多东西。
Well, Paul does some amazing reaction acting in this episode. If you are an actor and you would like to study great reactions, this is a real good one to study. Yeah. Well, what happens after this is that Toby's. Toby puts out a memo regarding PDA in the workplace and everyone's reading it. And Jim and Pam are like, what is this about? Toby is so passive aggressive. He really is.
好吧，保罗在这一集中做了一些惊人的反应表演。如果你是一名演员，并且想学习伟大的反应，这是一个非常好的学习案例。是的。好吧，在这之后发生的事情是托比发布了一份关于工作场所PDA的备忘录，每个人都在读它。吉姆和帕姆说，这是什么意思？托比真是太被动攻击了。他确实是。
He clearly has issue, but he's going to put out a memo. Come on, Toby. Well, Michael thinks that the memo is about that night that he and Jan did some stuff in his office. But, I mean, he says almost everyone was gone for the day. This is ridiculous, Toby. Yeah. And then Angela thinks it might be about her and Dwight. So she yells from across the room and makes this big statement that she's never been intimate with anyone in the office. And that is when Toby says, no, no, it was a complaint about Jim and Pam. And then he basically outs their relationship to the whole office. I mean, Toby, this is twice now because he did this with Oscar. And now. with Jim and Pam, he's announced that they're dating and everyone freaks out, but no one,
他显然有问题，但他要发布一份备忘录。得了吧，托比。好吧，迈克尔认为这份备忘录是关于那天晚上他和简在办公室里做的一些事情。但是，我的意思是，他说几乎每个人都下班了。这太荒谬了，托比。是的。然后安吉拉认为这可能是关于她和德怀特的。所以她从房间对面大喊，并发表了一个大声明，说她从未与办公室里的任何人亲密过。就在那时，托比说：“不，不，这是关于吉姆和帕姆的投诉。”然后他基本上向整个办公室曝光了他们的关系。我的意思是，托比，这是第二次了，因为他之前对奥斯卡也这么做过。现在
no one freaks out more than Michael. Well, Michael is giddy. Michael doesn't even know what to do with himself. And Steve's performance is so sweet. He is so genuinely excited that Jim and Pam are together. He makes them hold hands and he makes a big declaration. This day will go down in infamy. He makes you guys hold hands. And then he really bear hugs Jim and then he goes to hug you but your phone starts ringing and Pam's like up like rescued by my phone and he's like no no Pam let it ring let the bells of Dunder Mifflin chime out your love but then he has that really famous line that I've seen people right on their graduation hats I've seen it everywhere I've seen it like stitched on a pillow on a graduation hat it's it's so good
对吉姆和帕姆，他宣布他们在约会，每个人都吓坏了，但没有人，没有人比迈克尔更吓坏了。好吧，迈克尔是头晕目眩的。迈克尔甚至不知道该怎么办。史蒂夫的表演太甜了。他真的很高兴吉姆和帕姆在一起。他让他们握手，并发表了一个大声明。“这一天将因臭名昭著而载入史册。”他让你们握手。然后他真的给了吉姆一个熊抱，然后他去拥抱你，但你的电话开始响了，帕姆就像，“得救了，我的电话。”他说：“不，不，帕姆，让它响吧，让邓德·米夫林的钟声敲响你们的爱。”但随后他有了那句非常著名的台词，我见过人们把它写在毕业帽上，我到处都见过。我见过它像绣在枕头上，在毕业帽上，它太好了。
Say it, Ange. My heart soars with the eagle's nest. Incredible. Now, we said this episode was written by Mike Scher, and that has to be a Mike Scher special right there. It has to be. Now we see a series of talking heads, and Jenna, I was very curious about this, because you like to deep dive on positioning. Ooh, that sounds like that's what she said. That sounded different than what I think you mean.
说出来，Ange。“我的心随着鹰巢翱翔。”不可思议。现在，我们说过这一集是由迈克·舒尔编剧的，那一定是迈克·舒尔的特别之处。一定是。现在我们看到了一系列访谈片段，珍娜，我对此非常好奇，因为你喜欢深入研究站位。噢，听起来像是“那是她说的”。那听起来和我认为你的意思不一样。
But go on. As it was coming out of my mouth, I knew it was wrong. Oh, that's what she said. That's what she said. So Dwight's talking head, he's like, I don't see it. I think they could do better. He is sitting in front of the wall and off of his left shoulder is the bullpen, right? Yep.
但继续说。当它从我嘴里说出来时，我就知道错了。噢，那是她说的。那是她说的。所以德怀特的访谈片段，他说：“我不明白。我觉得他们可以做得更好。”他坐在墙前，他的左肩外是办公区，对吧？是的。
Yep. Then it cuts to me and I say, I'm not surprised. Pam is the office mattress, which is such a great line. But I'm sitting in front of the window with the wall to my right shoulder. Yeah, there's more wall. wall and more window depending on who's talking head it is. It's not always the exact same shot. I noticed that too. And then it cuts to Andy and he's framed the exact same way that Dwight was. And I realize I'm becoming one of the fans of the show where I'm like, hmm, is there something there? But I'm like,
是的。然后切到我，我说：“我不惊讶。帕姆是办公室的公共汽车。”这真是一句好台词。但我坐在窗前，墙在我的右肩。是的，有更多的墙。墙和更多的窗户，取决于那是谁的访谈片段。这并不总是完全相同的镜头。我也注意到了。然后切到安迪，他的构图和德怀特完全一样。我意识到我正在成为这部剧的粉丝之一，我想：“嗯，这里面有什么吗？”但我，
this is an interesting love triangle that's about to play out. And this is a little bit of a Dwight, Angela Andy sandwich. I don't think you are reading into it. I noticed the same thing. I feel like they purposely didn't set all the shots the same, and they also differentiated Angela from the two men. Yeah. That can't be an accident. It can't be.
这是一个即将上演的有趣的三角恋。这有点像德怀特、安吉拉、安迪三明治。我不认为你在过度解读。我也注意到了同样的事情。我觉得他们故意没有把所有的镜头设置得一样，而且他们还把安吉拉和那两个男人区分开了。是的。那不可能是偶然的。不可能是。
All right. Well, now we're going to get into the episode, right? We have our opening credits, and the first scene is the party planning committee. They're setting up for Ryan's return. Phyllis and Angela are hanging a banner that says, welcome back Ryan. Three minutes, 28 seconds. Skin alert. What's a skin alert?
好吧。好吧，现在我们要进入这一集了，对吧？我们有片头字幕，第一幕是派对策划委员会。他们正在为瑞安的回归做准备。菲利斯和安吉拉挂着一条横幅，上面写着“欢迎瑞安回来”。3分28秒。皮肤警报。什么是皮肤警报？
Well, my sweater in this episode, I feel like the dry, clean shrunk it, like it fit one day and then the next day it got a little tighter. And as I'm hanging the banner, you see like my midrift. Oh my gosh. That's very out of character for Angela Martin. It's very scandalous. It's scandalous. Well, double skin alert, Kelly arrives. Mm-hmm.
好吧，我在这一集里的毛衣，我觉得干洗缩水了，就像有一天它很合身，然后第二天它变得有点紧了。当我挂横幅时，你看到了我的腰部。天哪。这对安吉拉·马丁来说太不符合性格了。这太丢人了。这太丢人了。好吧，双重皮肤警报，凯利到了。嗯哼。
She is all joshed up. She's like, oh, is Ryan coming back today? I had no idea. She looks super cutie pie. She looks super cutie pie. We also in this scene have a list of that's what she says that Michael had ready to go. Oh, please, please read it. Here it is.
她打扮得漂漂亮亮的。她说：“噢，瑞安今天回来吗？我一点都不知道。”她看起来超级可爱。她看起来超级可爱。我们在这一幕里还有一份迈克尔准备好的“那是她说的”清单。噢，请，请读一下。在这里。
Can you make that straighter? That job looks hard. You should put your mouth on that. You might want to trim it a little. Yeah. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. I liked it when he said you might want to put your mouth on that.
你能把它弄直点吗？那份工作看起来很难。你应该把你的嘴放在上面。你可能想修剪一下。是的。嗯哼。嗯哼。我喜欢他说“你可能想把你的嘴放在上面”的时候。
And Pam says, how I don't understand how you were even planning to use that naturally. Yeah. And he was like, under his breath, he's like, if you, if you were blowing up balloons. I was just, I don't know. Just balloons. I had it ready. I was ready to go. Well, now we have sort of an interesting little spy shot.
帕姆说：“我不知道你本来打算怎么自然地使用它。”是的。他低声说：“如果你，如果你在吹气球。”我只是，我不知道。只是气球。我准备好了。我准备好了。好吧，现在我们有了一个有趣的间谍镜头。
We've got some black and white footage of the elevator bay, which is meant to be, I guess, security camera footage. Yeah, but they, this is like something we don't do on the show. So it was jarring to me when I saw it again because I hadn't seen this episode in so long. And I was like, whoa, what's up with the stuff? security camera footage. Well, what was odd is that we then switch to a spy shot from our regular documentary camera. Yeah. So it was a little bit, I found it a little bit odd as well, but that's what that black and white footage is supposed to be. And the reason they're showing this is because Dwight and Angela have met in this elevator vestibule so that he can present her with a new cat,
我们有一些电梯间的黑白镜头，我想那应该是安全摄像头镜头。是的，但他们，这是我们在剧里不做的事情。所以我再次看到它时感到很震惊，因为我很久没看这一集了。我说：“哇，安全摄像头镜头是怎么回事？”好吧，奇怪的是，我们随后切换到了我们常规纪录片摄像机的间谍镜头。是的。所以我发现它也有一点奇怪，但这就是那些黑白镜头应该有的样子。他们展示这个的原因是因为德怀特和安吉拉在这个电梯前厅见面，这样他就可以送给她一只猫，
a feral barn cat. Ferrell? Ferrell? Ferrell? How do you say feral? Feral, feral, feral. You say feral, tomato, you say feral, feral, a feral cat? A feral cat, feral, feral, right? It's tomato tomato, sam. Feral. Sam sided with me.
一只野生的谷仓猫。Ferrell？Ferrell？Ferrell？你怎么说feral？Feral，feral，feral。你说feral，番茄，你说feral，feral，一只feral猫？一只feral猫，feral，feral，对吧？这是番茄番茄，萨姆。Feral。萨姆站在我这边。
And Dwight says feral in the episode. But anyway, Jenna, we'll just chunk that aside and let you say feral. Listeners, do any of you say feral? Please write us. All right. So, yes, Dwight gives her garbage. And this poor cat, they put, like, stuff in its hair to make it look kind of grungy like it had been eating garbage. Well, we had a fan question from Rivka Wasserman. Did they gel the cat's hair before the shoot to make him look like more of a stray cat? Well, I reached out to Kim Ferry, and she said they did. that her memory is that the trainer had a little bit of honey. We had warned the trainer of this very well-trained domesticated cat that we wanted it to look feral.
德怀特在剧里说了feral。但无论如何，珍娜，我们先把那个“chunk”放在一边，让你说feral。听众们，你们有人说feral吗？请写信给我们。好吧。所以，是的，德怀特给了她Garbage（垃圾）。这只可怜的猫，他们在它的毛里放了东西，让它看起来有点脏兮兮的，就像它一直在吃垃圾一样。好吧，我们收到了Rivka Wasserman的粉丝提问。他们在拍摄前给猫的毛涂了发胶，让它看起来更像流浪猫吗？好吧，我联系了Kim Ferry，她说他们确实这么做了。她的记忆是训练师用了一点蜂蜜。我们警告过这只训练有素的家猫的训练师，我们想让它看起来很野。
And so they suggested something natural like honey to kind of rough up the cat's fur. And so that's what they used. Yes, these trainers were so great with the cats. And obviously, honey isn't going to do anything. You know, that's just like organic. I do have amazing memories of this scene. I want you guys to know that this cat was crawling all over rain, all over him. Well, you can see it in the episode.
所以他们建议用像蜂蜜这样天然的东西来弄乱猫的毛。所以这就是他们用的。是的，这些训练师对猫太好了。显然，蜂蜜不会有任何影响。你知道，那只是有机的。我对这一幕有惊人的记忆。我想让你们知道，这只猫在雷恩身上爬来爬去。好吧，你可以在剧里看到。
Like every shot, the cat is in a different position. It kept jumping out of his arms. And so we really had to sort of deliver the emotion of the scene, but get our lines out quickly because this thing was climbing off rain and wanted to go exploring, the whole scene. well my favorite is the shot where it's like clearly crawling over his shoulder and then one second later he's holding it like a baby yeah in his arms because it's amazing clearly the cat was everywhere the cat was everywhere and the cat wranglers were like stepping in and being like okay here try holding him this way try this when the cat jumps out of rain's arms at the end that was
就像每一个镜头，猫的位置都不一样。它一直从他怀里跳出来。所以我们真的必须传达这一幕的情感，但要快速说出我们的台词，因为这东西在雷恩身上爬，想去探索，整整一幕。好吧，我最喜欢的是它明显爬过他肩膀的镜头，然后一秒钟后他像抱婴儿一样抱着它，是的，在怀里，因为这太神奇了，显然猫到处都是，猫到处都是，猫的驯兽师介入并说：“好吧，这里，试着这样抱着它，试着这个。”当猫在最后从雷恩怀里跳出来时，那是
like the easiest moment to film because it wanted it wanted to go explore well angch a lot of people asked if this was the same cat that Andy gives you later, that becomes bandit? I mean, it's, I wouldn't think it was meant to be the same cat. Like, I think what they're thinking is, oh, Dwight lets this cat go, and then years later, Andy finds it again and calls it bandit. Well, that would be hilarious, but that was never conveyed to us in the script. It's just that Andy wants to give Angela a cat. What I found interesting about that, and obviously we're going to get to that episode is that Angela accepts the cat from Andy, right? Yeah. But does not accept the cat from Dwight. And does it right in front of Dwight to sort of, you know, just really drive the point
拍摄起来最容易的时刻，因为它想去探索。好吧，安吉拉，很多人问这是否是安迪后来给你的那只猫，后来变成了Bandit？我的意思是，我不认为它应该是同一只猫。就像，我想他们想的是，“噢，德怀特放走了这只猫，然后几年后，安迪又发现了它，叫它Bandit。”好吧，那会很搞笑，但剧本里从未向我们传达过这一点。只是安迪想给安吉拉一只猫。我发现有趣的是，显然我们要讲到那一集，安吉拉接受了安迪给的猫，对吧？是的。但没有接受德怀特给的猫。而且就在德怀特面前做这件事，为了，你知道，真的把这一点强调出来。
home that he's not, he's not her fella anymore. Well, as a person who worked in animal rescue for years and years, I will tell you that I don't recommend giving pets as gifts because so many of the pets that are surrendered were gifts that people were not prepared to take care of in the long run or they break up or whatever happens. I just think people should pick their own pets or really what my mom always said is let the pet pick you. That's how you get your match. Yeah. I like that. I definitely feel our pets picked us for sure. Yeah, that's how we got sunny. We went into this rescue center because we were told that one of the volunteers was going to bring in this box of fluffy gray and white cats.
家里，他不再是她的男朋友了。嗯，作为一个在动物救援中心工作了多年的人，我想说我不建议把宠物当作礼物送人，因为很多被遗弃的宠物都是人们没有做好长期照顾准备的礼物，或者他们分手了，或者发生了什么别的事。我只是觉得人们应该自己挑选宠物，或者正如我妈妈常说的，让宠物来挑选你。这就是你找到命中注定的那个它的方式。是的，我喜欢这个说法。我绝对觉得我们的宠物肯定是挑选了我们。是的，我们就是这样得到桑尼的。我们走进这家救援中心，因为有人告诉我们，其中一名志愿者要带一箱毛茸茸的灰白相间的猫过来。
They were so cute. They'd sent us pictures. My daughter was all excited. And we got there and the woman was running late. So they took us into a room with all of these adoptable cats and kittens. And this one little scrappy orange fellow would not leave us alone. I always say it was like he walked up to us and he was like, hey guys, what's up? Good to see you.
它们太可爱了。他们给我们发了照片。我女儿非常兴奋。我们到了那里，那位女士迟到了。所以他们把我们带进了一个房间，里面有所有可以领养的猫和幼猫。这只瘦小、好斗的橘色小家伙一直缠着我们不放。我常说，就像他走到我们面前，好像在说，嘿，伙计们，怎么了？很高兴见到你们。
My name's sunny. I'll be coming home with you. You can take a look at these other guys if you want, but I will be your cat. And that's kind of how we got sunny. He wouldn't leave us alone. We could have never been happier. That was Biscuit. Biscuit just tried to hide in my sweatshirt. And I thought, well, you got to come home with me now. Exactly. My sweatshirt is your home. Well, listen, switching gears back to the show. Yeah, don't get us started on our rescue pets. It would be a huge tangent. Pam and Jim are going to go out to Toby and offer to sign one of the famous love documents.
我叫桑尼。我要跟你们回家了。如果你们愿意，可以看看其他家伙，但我会成为你们的猫。我们就是这样得到桑尼的。他一直缠着我们不放。我们再高兴不过了。那是饼干。饼干刚才试图躲进我的运动衫里。我想，好吧，你现在得跟我回家了。没错。我的运动衫就是你的家。好了，听着，话题转回节目。是的，别让我们开始聊我们的救援宠物了。那会是一个巨大的题外话。帕姆和吉姆打算去找托比，提出签署一份著名的恋爱协议。
yes the relationship disclosure form and Toby's like you know what um that's only for people who are serious and he's sort of implying this isn't serious right because you know Toby has his big crush on Pam and so he's hoping this is casual but Jenna there's a great scene in the bloopers where at the end of the scene Toby just tries to hold Pam's hand in front of Jim and you guys couldn't get through it you just start laughing I remember trying to shoot that I don't think we ever got it and that's why we never included it. But it was also just something we thought was so funny in the moment. It was like an improvisation that Toby would slowly try to hold Pam's hand during this scene and squeeze her hand.
是的，关系披露表，托比说，你知道吗，嗯，那只针对认真的人，他暗示这并不认真，对吧？因为你知道托比对帕姆有很大的好感，所以他希望这只是随意的，但是珍娜，花絮里有一个很棒的场景，在场景结束时，托比只是试图在吉姆面前握住帕姆的手，你们俩没法演下去，你们就开始笑，我记得当时试图拍摄那个场景，我想我们从来没拍成，这就是为什么我们没把它放进去。但这也是我们当时觉得非常有趣的事情。这就像是一种即兴表演，托比会在这个场景中慢慢试图握住帕姆的手，并捏她的手。
Yeah. And Jim's like, what's happening? Well, then Ryan returns. Yes, Ryan with his new look and his love of Blackberries walks in. Oh, my God. BJ's performance is so good when he's absorbed in his phone. And Pam's like, hey, Ryan. Well, he's like one second.
是的。吉姆说，发生了什么事？好吧，然后瑞安回来了。是的，瑞安带着他的新造型和他对黑莓手机的热爱走了进来。天哪。BJ在沉迷于手机时的表演太棒了。帕姆说，嘿，瑞安。他却说，等一下。
And then, like, after he's done typing, he puts it down and he's like, hey, Pam, how's it going? It was so good. Well, you know, in this scene, I know what you guys are all really here to find out about is a sad plant alert. Oh, no. Six minutes, seven seconds, sad plant. I think Pam, now for sure the plants aren't going to have a chance. because she's in love. Yeah, she doesn't have time for that.
然后，在他打完字后，他放下手机说，嘿，帕姆，最近怎么样？太棒了。嗯，你知道，在这个场景里，我知道你们大家真正想了解的是悲伤植物警报。哦，不。六分七秒，悲伤植物。我想帕姆，现在肯定植物没机会了。因为她恋爱了。是的，她没时间管那个。
It's the tiniest little, like two, like green leaves sticking out of the pot. It's like so tiny. Well, the thing that I remember about this scene, Angela, is when the character of Kevin runs up to Ryan and like ruffles his hair. He gives him a noogie. He like puts him in a headlock and gives him a nuggy. Those guys could not get through that moment. Every time it would make B.J. laugh. BJ thought it was so funny.
那是最小的，就像两片绿叶从花盆里伸出来。它太小了。嗯，关于这个场景我记得的事情，安吉拉，是当凯文这个角色跑向瑞安并揉乱他的头发时。他给了他一个“noogie”（揉头）。他像把他锁喉一样，给了他一个“noogie”。那些家伙没法演完那一刻。每次都会让BJ笑场。BJ觉得这太搞笑了。
And he would break. And I remember we couldn't get through it. And Brian, too. I loved it when he's like, fire guy. And then Andy comes over and he's like, fire guy. And Brian is Kevin. It's like, you weren't here for that. I know.
他会笑场。我记得我们没法拍完。还有布莱恩也是。我喜欢他喊“火男”的时候。然后安迪走过来，他说“火男”。布莱恩是凯文。就像是，你当时不在场。我知道。
And then Andy says, here for what? Yeah. So good. It's so good. Well, we had a fan question from Lauren C. She wanted to know about Ryan's new look. You know, he's got the facial stubble. He's slicked his hair back.
然后安迪说，在这儿干什么？是的。太棒了。太棒了。嗯，我们有一个来自劳伦·C的粉丝提问。她想了解瑞安的新造型。你知道，他留了胡茬。他把头发向后梳了。
He's wearing a fancy suit. Lauren wants to know, was BJ told to grow facial hair for this season where he's the boss? Or did he just personally decide to grow some? Well, I texted BJ about this. He said this look was definitely not a personal choice. He said he thinks it was a pitch by Gene and Lee. At first, the pitch was a goatee. But Greg said no.
他穿着一套时髦的西装。劳伦想知道，BJ是被要求在这个他当老板的季节留胡子吗？还是他自己决定留的？嗯，我给BJ发了短信问这件事。他说这个造型绝对不是个人选择。他说他认为是吉恩和李的提议。起初，提议是留山羊胡。但格雷格说不行。
He said it was too on the nose. Yeah, go-toe is too much. The whole look was very kind of like Gordon Gecko, you know, the movie Wall Street. It was like, you know, Ryan thinks he's the king of New York now. Yes. B.J. said that he always just kind of rolled with pitches like this. And then he said case and point, the upcoming blonde hair. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Ryan's going to go through a few looks before this whole thing is over. Well, Ryan in the scene, though, really puts Michael in his place. And everyone, he's like, hey, you know what? Enough. This is inappropriate, and it stops right now. And the whole bullpen, it's like, you could hear a pin drop. We're like, oh, my God. And then Michael has this fantastic talking head. I just loved it so much. He's like, yeah, maybe, you know, maybe he spoke to me like that, but there was a twinkle in his eye. And that twinkle said, dude, we're friends. And, and, You know me, and I'd never take you for granted in a million years. I miss you. I love you. And then he's like, he goes on and on.
他说那太明显了。是的，山羊胡太过了。整个造型非常像戈登·盖柯，你知道，电影《华尔街》。就像是，你知道，瑞安现在认为自己是纽约之王。是的。BJ说他总是顺从这样的提议。然后他说，举个例子，即将到来的金发。哦，是的。是的。在这一切结束之前，瑞安会经历几种造型。嗯，不过瑞安在这个场景里，真的让迈克尔认清了自己的位置。他对每个人说，嘿，你知道吗？够了。这很不合适，现在就停止。整个办公区，就像是，你能听到针掉在地上的声音。我们就像，哦，天哪。然后迈克尔有一个精彩的谈话头。我太喜欢了。他说，是的，也许，你知道，也许他那样对我说话，但他眼里闪烁着光芒。那光芒说，伙计，我们是朋友。而且，而且，你知道我，我永远不会把你视为理所当然。我想你。我爱你。然后他说，他没完没了地说。
He's like, his words, not mine. This episode, in addition to having great facial expressions from Paul, has amazing Michael talking heads. They're so good. Well, now everyone's going to meet in the conference room so that Ryan can unveil his Dunder-Mifflin Infinity program. I have to point out something. First of all, where did the giant TV screen come from? It's not in there when the party planning committee is setting up. Secondly, you might notice there's no more banner on the wall because there's a deleted scene where as they all come in, on the banner, Kelly has written, she's scratched out Ryan and it says, welcome back, asshole.
他说，他的话，不是我的。这一集，除了保罗有很棒的面部表情外，还有精彩的迈克尔谈话头。它们太棒了。好吧，现在大家都要在会议室开会，这样瑞安就可以揭幕他的邓德·米夫林无限计划。我必须指出一件事。首先，那个巨大的电视屏幕是从哪儿来的？当派对策划委员会布置时，它不在那里。其次，你可能会注意到墙上没有横幅了，因为有一个删除的场景，当他们都进来时，在横幅上，凯利写了，她划掉了瑞安，上面写着，欢迎回来，混蛋。
And Michael runs up to it and quickly rips it down, so Ryan won't see it. That is amazing. Well, in this scene, Michael announces two pretty big things. Number one, all essential personnel will be receiving an office Blackberry phone. And second, we are soon to be launching the Dunder Mifflin Infinity website that is going to streamline ordering. It's going to streamline efficiency. These are his two big announcements. Yeah, he says the company is going to get younger and sleaker.
迈克尔跑过去，迅速把它撕了下来，这样瑞安就不会看到。那太棒了。嗯，在这个场景里，迈克尔宣布了两件大事。第一，所有核心员工都将收到一部办公室黑莓手机。第二，我们很快就要推出邓德·米夫林无限网站，这将简化订购。它将简化效率。这是他的两个重大公告。是的，他说公司会变得更年轻、更时尚。
And this starts a Creed storyline that is so fantastic. Creed played this so well. His reaction to the words younger, sleeker, he starts looking around. And then he goes up to Ryan at the end. He's like, when's this a new website launch? And then he's like, cool beans. Like he's trying to be hip or something. Well, he runs into Michael's office after the meeting.
这开启了一个克里德的故事线，太棒了。克里德演得太好了。他对“更年轻、更时尚”这些词的反应，他开始四处张望。然后他在最后走到瑞安面前。他说，这个新网站什么时候上线？然后他说，酷豆子（Cool beans）。就像他试图赶时髦一样。嗯，他在会议后跑进了迈克尔的办公室。
And he's like, you realize what this means, right? You, me, Sammy, Phyllis, the chick you hit with your car. We're all goners. Who is Sammy? Who is Sammy? Who does Creed think Sammy is? I don't know. Did he mean Stanley?
他说，你意识到这意味着什么，对吧？你，我，萨米，菲利斯，那个被你车撞到的女孩。我们都完了。萨米是谁？萨米是谁？克里德认为萨米是谁？我不知道。他是指斯坦利吗？
Probably. Also, he has sat across from Meredith for years and couldn't think of her name. It's incredible. It's just great. Well, he calls my character Andrea, the office bitch. So, Sammy is probably Stanley. So now we have a very cute. scene back in the flirt room, the flirt room, break room, Jim and Pam are eating lunch together,
可能吧。而且，他坐在梅雷迪思对面多年，却想不起她的名字。这太不可思议了。这太棒了。嗯，他称我的角色为安德里亚，办公室婊子。所以，萨米可能是斯坦利。现在我们有一个非常可爱的场景，回到调情室，调情室，休息室，吉姆和帕姆在一起吃午饭，
and Jim's like, I can't believe I, you know, didn't tell you this, this is going to blow your mind. And he tells Pam that Dwight and Angela are dating. And Pam's like, yeah, I already knew that. It's been like a long time. Since before your barbecue, she says. Yeah. And then I love this. This next moment is just titled Phyllis Sass. Phyllis. walks in and says, sorry, I didn't know you guys were in here. And Jim says, oh, we're just sitting here. And Phyllis goes, couldn't see your hands. What? What is she applying? First of all, she knew they were in there. Okay. So she knew they were in there. She went to find Pam to tell her this information. Secondly, couldn't see your hands. Well, and then John does this awesome move
吉姆说，我不敢相信我，你知道，没告诉你这件事，这会让你大吃一惊。他告诉帕姆，德怀特和安吉拉在约会。帕姆说，是的，我早就知道了。已经很久了。她说，在你烧烤之前。是的。然后我喜欢这个。接下来的这一刻标题就是“菲利斯毒舌”。菲利斯走进来，说，抱歉，我不知道你们在这儿。吉姆说，哦，我们只是坐在这儿。菲利斯说，没看见你们的手。什么？她在暗示什么？首先，她知道他们在里面。好吧。所以她知道他们在里面。她去找帕姆告诉她这个信息。其次，没看见你们的手。嗯，然后约翰做了一个很棒的动作
with his hands, where he shows them to camera like, they're so clearly right here. I love. loved that moment. That was a Krasinski special right there. No, it was perfect. And then Phyllis with a smile. Sass with a smile is like, you know, I'm glad you guys are dating. But Pam, when we get a new client, you have to just send it to, you know, the first available salesperson, not whoever you're sleeping with that week. That week! It's like Phyllis and Angela both are in cahoots this episode because Pam is the office mattress. Well, Angela, I'm calling this a fan sass catch from Snea G. She points out the major Phyllis Sass as well.
用他的手，他向镜头展示它们，就像，它们明明就在这儿。我爱那一刻。那绝对是克拉辛斯基的招牌动作。不，那太完美了。然后菲利斯带着微笑。带着微笑的毒舌说，你知道，我很高兴你们在约会。但是帕姆，当我们有新客户时，你必须把它发给，你知道，第一个可用的销售员，而不是你那周在和谁睡觉。那周！就像菲利斯和安吉拉在这一集里串通一气，因为帕姆是办公室的床垫。嗯，安吉拉，我把这称为来自Snea G的粉丝毒舌捕捉。她也指出了菲利斯的主要毒舌。
But she added this. According to Phyllis, Pam is in charge of assigning clients to salesmen randomly. Well, according to my husband, who's in a similar kind of office, this is a lot of power given to one person. That is not how the customers are typically, assigned to salespeople. The assignment is based on the client's zip code or county to ensure that there is always a clear rule regarding this assignment. Well, I have to say, after college before I moved to Los Angeles, I was the only receptionist slash administrative assistant at a small
但她补充了这一点。根据菲利斯的说法，帕姆负责随机分配客户给销售员。嗯，根据我丈夫的说法，他在一个类似的办公室，这赋予了一个人很大的权力。这不是客户通常分配给销售员的方式。分配是基于客户的邮政编码或县，以确保关于此分配始终有明确的规则。嗯，我必须说，大学毕业后，在我搬到洛杉矶之前，我是密苏里州一家小型海洋音响公司的唯一接待员兼行政助理。海洋音响。他们制造像船用的防水立体声系统。谢谢。我需要澄清。谢谢。不客气。好的。每当我们接到海洋音响的推销电话时。
marine audio company in Missouri. And marine audio. They made like water-resistant, waterproof stereo systems for boats. Thank you. I needed clarity. Thank you. You're welcome. Okay. Whenever we got a cold call for marine audio.
对。嗯哼。我就会随机把他们转给一个可用的销售助理。这算是我的决定。哇。是的。这种情况不常发生，但偶尔，我们会接到推销电话。帕姆的工作有这种奇怪的等级制度。
Right. Mm-hmm. I would just transfer them randomly to an available sales associate. It was kind of my call. Wow. Yeah. It didn't come up very often, but every once in a while, we would get a cold call. Pam's job has this weird hierarchy.
首先，她必须向安吉拉要零用钱。然后她有这些悲伤的植物和安吉拉希望她摆出来的糖果。但现在我们发现她把客户转给销售部门。是的。而且她是迈克尔的秘书。这非常有层次。你知道，我很多帕姆的东西都是基于我在这个海洋音响公司的工作。人数和邓德·米夫林差不多。有一个仓库，
First of all, she has to ask Angela for petty cash. And then she has these sad plants and this candy that Angela expects her to put out. But now we find out she passes on clients to the sales department. Yeah. And she's Michael's secretary. It's very layered. You know, I based a lot of my Pam stuff off of this job that I had at this Marine Audio Place. It was about the same number of people as Dunder Mifflin. There was a warehouse where
我们运送所有订单。我简直就是帕姆。我早上煮咖啡。我接电话。我做每个人的行政工作。你在那里和人约会过吗？我没有。聪明。是的。我没有在海洋音响和任何人约会。好的。现在我们有一个吉姆的谈话头。他说，这就是为什么我们等了这么久才告诉别人。你注意到吉姆面对办公区，背对着外面吗？没有。因为他的未来在办公区。他的未来是帕姆，她在外面。
we shipped all the orders. And I was literally Pam. I made the coffee in the morning. I answered the phones. I did everyone's administrative work. Did you date anyone there? I did not. Smart. Yeah. I did not date anyone at Marine Audio. Okay. Well, now we have a gym talking head. And he says, that is why we waited so long to tell people. Did you notice Jim is facing the bullpen with his back to the outside? No. Because his future's in the bullpen. His future is Pam and she's out there.
是的。他现在在邓德·米夫林有了未来。是的。在他心里。这很有趣。我不知道。我想回去一秒钟。好的。
Yeah. He now has a future at Dunder Mifflin. Yes. In his heart. It's very interesting. I don't know. I want to go back one second. Okay.
就一秒钟。我已经大声想了好几集了，吉姆和帕姆是什么时候告诉对方他们共同知道德怀特和安吉拉的事的？这一集终于揭晓了。就在现在，在工作中。什么？我们相信这个吗？这花了好久。不，我相信，因为我认为他们坠入爱河并最终在一起的开始，对他们来说太特别了。我的意思是，我只是觉得他们真的沉浸在彼此之中。现在，现在，现在，他们到了约会几个月的地步，他们就像，哦，顺便问一下，你知道吗？
Just one second. I have been wondering for several. episodes now out loud, when did Jim and Pam tell one another about their shared knowledge of Dwight and Angela? And it is finally revealed in this episode. It's right now at work. What? Do we believe this? This took forever. No, I believe it because I think the beginning of them falling in love and finally getting to be together, it was so special to them. I mean, I just feel like they were really absorbed with one another. And now, now, now, they're at the point they've been dating a few months where they're like oh by the way did you know
你知道我的意思吗，我认为他们到了那个阶段。嗯，我想他们在那几周里处于那种爱的迷雾中。我信。嗯，你不信，用你那毒舌的嗯嗯。我想那会是我第一次晚餐约会时说的第一件事。我不这么认为。嘿，顺便说一下，我不认为在爱了这个家伙多年后，你第一次和他单独相处时，他会说，等等，等等，我一会儿再吻你，首先我们需要谈谈德怀特。丹尼尔，你可能是对的。好吧，现在迈克尔和瑞安在迈克尔的办公室里，瑞安正忙着在黑莓手机上打字。你还记得当时雷恩和我在现实生活中都有黑莓手机吗？我们就是瑞安，我们一直在用黑莓手机，我们太烦人了。我想布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳也有一个。
you know what i mean i think they're at that place hmm i think they were sort of in that fog of love for a few weeks i buy it hmm you do not buy it by your sassy hmm hmm i think it would have been the first thing i would have said on our first dinner date i don't think so hey by the way i don't think after years of loving this guy the first time you're alone with him he's like wait wait wait I'll kiss you in a second first we need to talk about toy Daniel you're probably right all right well now Michael and Ryan are in Michael's office Ryan is so busy typing on his blackberry do you remember at this time rain and I both had blackberries in real life and we were Ryan we were constantly on our blackberries we were so annoying I think Brian Baumgartner had one too
抱歉。我有一个。我们都有一个。那就是你有的。你有一个黑莓手机。没有智能手机。你有一个黑莓手机，你不能用手机拍照，这就是为什么你和我有很多照片，像老式的照片，因为我们会带相机去片场，我们会拍照，然后我们会去商场的那个亭子，我们会冲洗照片。是的，是真的。但我们现在可以在工作时收发邮件，当我们站在场景之间时，因为我们有黑莓手机。是的，我们的拇指太快了。我们变得非常擅长。我是一个坚持者。我直到很晚才买iPhone，因为我太依恋我的黑莓手机了。我和你一样。我真的很反感智能手机屏幕那种东西，我喜欢按屏幕。我真的很喜欢那种有形的按钮。我一直用我的手机，直到
Excuse me. I had one. We all had one. That's what you had. You had a Blackberry. There were no smartphones. You had a Blackberry and you did not take pictures with your phone, which is why you and I have so many photos like old-timey photos because we would bring our cameras to the set and we would take pictures and then we would go to the mall to that kiosk and we would develop our photos. Yep, it's true. But we could now do emails at work while we would. were standing between scenes because we had our BlackBerry. Yes, and our thumbs were so fast. We got so good at it. And I was a holdout. I did not get the iPhone to way late because I was so attached to my BlackBerry. I was the same. I really resented the smartphone screen thing where I like pressed on the screen. I was real into the like the tangible button thing. I kept on my phone for
很久以后，当我终于买了iPhone时，你知道你可以选择声音吗？所以它会咔哒，咔哒，咔哒，咔哒，咔哒，咔哒，咔哒。是的。因为我依恋那个声音。嗯，迈克尔在这个场景里想确保他们达成共识。一切照旧。瑞安却说，不，这和一切照旧相反。我们实际上是在扔掉旧剧本。我们从头开始。我们想要一家更年轻、更快的公司。这引出了迈克尔一个令人难以置信的谈话头，简直不可思议。是的，他，我的意思是，他们有一个寄宿在他家的外国交换生，他说我们叫他我的兄弟，因为他就是。
a long time when I finally got an iPhone, you know how you can choose the sound? So it goes click, click, click, click, click, click, click. Yeah. Because I was attached to the sound. Well, Michael in this scene wants to make sure that they're on the same page. It's business as usual. And Ryan is like, no, it's the opposite of business as usual. We're literally throwing out the old playbook. We're starting over. We want a younger, faster company. Which leads us into just an incredible talking head by Michael, just incredible. Yeah, he, I mean, they had a foreign exchange student that lived with him, and he said we called him my brother because he was.
然后他回到了前南斯拉夫，他拿走了迈克尔所有的蓝色牛仔裤。是的，迈克尔整个冬天都得穿短裤。为什么，珍娜？为什么？为什么他妈妈不能给他买任何替换的蓝色牛仔裤过冬？我不知道。但我们有几个人写信来想知道这是否就是迈克尔今天垂涎他的蓝色牛仔裤，以及为什么他干洗它们的原因，因为这个创伤性事件，这个外国交换生
And then he went back to what was formerly Yugoslavia, and he took all of Michael's blue jeans. Yeah, Michael had to wear shorts all winter. Why, Jenna? Why? Why couldn't his mother buy him any replacement blue jeans for the winter? I don't know. but we had several people write in and wonder if this is why Michael covets his blue jeans today and why he dry cleans them because of this traumatic event where this foreign exchange
偷走了他所有的牛仔裤。他妈妈惩罚他，不让他买任何新的。但是的，他说，这就是瑞安的样子，一个偷你牛仔裤的假兄弟。嗯，珍娜，我们可能应该休息一下。在我们休息之前，我想让你知道，在这一集的这个部分有一个删除的场景，迈克尔收到一条消息，他对帕姆说，嘿，你能把它放进我的黑莓手机里吗？我现在太忙了，没法输入。你能把它放进我的黑莓手机里吗？他发表了一大通演讲。所以就像是，我正在使用我的黑莓手机。帕姆，请把它输入我的黑莓手机。然后
student stole all his jeans. And his mother punished him by not letting him buy any new ones. But yeah, he says, that is what Ryan is like, a fake brother who steals your jeans. Well, Jenna, we should probably take a break. Before we do, I want you to know there was a deleted scene that would have happened in this area of the episode where Michael gets a message and he says to Pam, hey, can you put that in my Blackberry? I'm too busy right now to input it. Will you put that in my Blackberry? And he makes a big speech. So it's like, I am using my Blackberry. Pam, please enter that in my Blackberry. And then
有一个帕姆的谈话头。她说，是的，迈克尔不知道怎么用他的黑莓手机。所以当他说让我把它放进他的黑莓手机时，他的意思是让我把它写在便利贴上，贴在黑莓手机上面。然后你看到他的手机被覆盖了，他的黑莓手机被所有这些微小的便利贴覆盖了。你会喜欢那个的。我会喜欢的。那是给你的黑莓手机留言的最好方式。我知道。只要贴个便利贴就行。好吧。嗯，我们要休息一下，回来聊聊凯利和瑞安的戏剧。哦，天哪。凯利。凯利处于罕见的状态。现在我们在附件里，凯利告诉瑞安，你知道吗，我做得很好。
there's a Pam talking head. And she goes, yeah, Michael doesn't know how to use his Blackberry. And so when he says for me to put it in his Blackberry, he means for me to write it on a post it and stick it on top of the blackberry. And then you see his phone is covered, his blackberry is covered with all these little miniature post-it note stickies. You would love that. I would love that. That's the best way to give you a message on your blackberry. I know. Just put a sticky on it. All right. Well, we'll take a break and we will be back with some Kelly Ryan drama. Oh, man. Kelly. Kelly's in rare form. So now we're in the Annex, and Kelly is telling Ryan, you know what, I am doing great.
事实上，我正在和很多男人约会。他说，凯利，她说，什么？她气坏了。而且，当然，托比，托比在听整个谈话。嗯，然后凯利说她怀孕了。是的。然后她有一个谈话头，她现在只是摇头。这让我大声笑了出来。
In fact, I am dating a lot of guys. And he's like, Kelly, and she's like, what? She's like so pissed. And, of course, Toby, Toby is listening to the whole conversation. Well, then Kelly says she's pregnant. Yeah. And then she has a talking head where she just shakes her head now. It made me laugh out loud.
太搞笑了。然后这就是她让瑞安和她去吃晚餐的方式。他说，好吧。她说，什么？她说，我打算留下这个孩子。他说，我现在不能谈这个。我们去吃晚餐吧。然后她有一个谈话头，她说，我们有约会了。是的。
It was so funny. And then this is how she gets Ryan to go to dinner with her. He's like, okay. She's like, I'm keeping the baby. And he's like, I can't talk about this now. Let's go to dinner. And then she has a talking head where she's like, we have a date. Yes.
嗯，在这个谈话中，瑞安说，我确实认真对待我们的关系。凯伦六个月前约我出去，我说不。哦，他真是个骗子。他真是个骗子。嗯，这是一个来自汉娜·库尔森的粉丝提问。我们认为凯伦真的约过瑞安吗？还是他只是为了让凯利嫉妒才这么说的？不，他是在试图向凯利展示他有多忠诚。事实是他勾引了凯伦并约她出去，他们在女性欣赏那一集的浴室里谈过这件事。没错。提到了。吉姆说，是的，她告诉过我那件事。所以不，瑞安在这里是个老骗子。嗯，我们收到
Well, also in this conversation, Ryan says, I did take our relationship seriously. Karen asked me out six months ago and I said no. Oh, he's such a. a liar. He's such a liar. Well, this was a fan question from Hannah Coulson. Do we think Karen really asked Ryan out or was he just saying that to make Kelly jealous? No, he was trying to show Kelly how committed he was. The truth is he hit on Karen and asked her out and they talked about it in the bathroom in women's appreciation. That's right. It came up. Jim was like, yeah, she told me about that. So no, Ryan's being a big old liar right here. Well, we got.
了一封来自巴西雷纳塔的信，关于瑞安和凯利的恋情。好的，雷纳塔。她对此非常热情，这就是她要说的。好的。她说，我非常喜欢这一集，但我只是需要对凯利和瑞安的关系发表评论，以及它有多么令人共鸣，以及它不应该有多么令人共鸣。我在生活中遇到过很多瑞安，女士们，这不值得。我只是想给你们所有人送去一些爱，并说你们值得拥有一个会把你们的爱放在首位的人。所以我希望这段疯狂的关系能教给你们一些关于什么不该接受的东西，因为你们值得拥有更多。我不知道，也许外面有人需要听到这个。那是来自雷纳塔的。雷纳塔，掌声。你是对的。你绝对是对的。在这一场景中发生的另一件事
a letter from Renata in Brazil about the Ryan and Kelly relationship. Okay, Renata. She was very passionate about it and here is what she had to say. Okay. She says, I love this episode so much, but I just need to make a comment about Kelly and Ryan's relationship and how relatable it can be and how it shouldn't be. I've met a lot of Ryan's in my life and ladies, it is not worth it. I just want to send some love to all of you and say that you deserve someone who's going to put your love on top. So I hope that this crazy relationship will teach you something about what not to accept because you deserve more. I don't know, maybe someone out there needs to hear this. That's from Renata. Renata, applause. You're right. You're absolutely right. Another thing going on during the scene
是我们很快看到菲利斯和斯坦利试图弄明白黑莓手机。而且珍娜，如果你去12分41秒，在深背景里，你可以看到我在上网。你看到我在滚动浏览。我记下了一些东西。我滚动浏览更多。我可能在购物。那太棒了。嗯，然后我们进入安吉拉和德怀特在厨房里进行另一次背靠背谈话。
is we quickly see Phyllis and Stanley trying to figure out the Blackberry. And Jenna, If you go to 12 minutes, 41 seconds, in the deep background, you can just see me surfing the Internet. You see me like scrolling through. I jot something down. I scroll through some more. I'm probably shopping. That's amazing. Well, then we move into Angela and Dwight having another one of their back-to-back conversations in the kitchen.
是的。但你知道我们要感谢谁带来这一刻吗？谁？帕姆。为什么？在一个本应出现在这之前的删除场景中，帕姆要给安吉拉一些建议。萨姆，我要播放片段。他试图给我一只新猫来代替斯普林克尔斯。
Yes. But do you know who we have to thank for this moment? Who? Pam. Why? In a deleted scene that would have come right before this, Pam is going to give Angela some advice. Sam, I'm going to play the clip. He tried to give me a new cat to replace sprinkles.
好像你能代替斯普林克尔斯一样。他只是很难表达自己。嗯，这真的让我很心烦。你可能注意到了，但上周，我一直是个狂暴的婊子。我该怎么办？看，这段关系有很多好的部分，对吧？不关你的事。对。
As if you could replace sprinkles. He just has a hard time expressing himself. Well, it's really upsetting me. You've probably noticed, but this last week, I've been a raging bitch. What should I do? Look, there's a lot of good parts to this relationship, right? None of your business. Right.
嗯，试着专注于那些。为什么你们今晚不去吃晚餐，谈谈你们总是谈论的任何事情？也许你是对的。是的。我说也许。所以是的，安吉拉和帕姆在电梯处见面，帕姆给了她这个关系建议。
Well, just try to focus on those. Why don't you guys go out to dinner tonight and talk about whatever you always talk about? Maybe you're right. Yeah. I said maybe. So yes, Angela and Pam met at the elevators and Pam gives her this relationship advice.
我太难过了，那没能放进去。那太令人愉快了。太有趣了。太有趣了。所以安吉拉真的听取了帕姆的建议，觉得，好吧，这里有值得争取的东西。我会约他出去吃晚餐，而且，你知道，也许我能原谅他，我会从这顿晚餐开始。嗯，德怀特主动提出为你做晚餐。他说他会为你做面条和花椰菜，配上一份烤土豆。我想让你知道，安吉拉。什么？不管什么原因，这导致我谷歌了面条和花椰菜。
I am so sad that did not make it in. That was delightful. It was so fun. It was so fun. So Angela actually takes Pam's advice and is like, okay, there's something worth fighting for here. I'll ask him out to dinner and, you know, maybe I'll be able to forgive him and I'll start with this dinner. Well, Dwight offers to make you dinner. He says he will cook you noodles and cauliflower with a side of baked potato. I want you to know, Angela. What? For whatever reason, this caused me to Google noodles and cauliflower.
我只是把它看作是，她喜欢她的淀粉，而且她是素食主义者。你发现了什么？面条和花椰菜是一道非常受欢迎的素食菜肴。哦。纽约时报烹饪页面有一个看起来很好吃的食谱。我想我要做它。哦，发给我。伙计们，谷歌面条和花椰菜。
I just saw it as like, she loves her starches and she's a vegetarian. What'd you find? Noodles and cauliflower is a very popular vegetarian dish. Oh. The New York Times cooking page had a recipe that looks so good. I think I'm going to make it. Oh, send it to me. Guys, Google noodles and cauliflower.
好的。这是一个宝库。太棒了。我等不及了。哦，天哪。谁知道呢？嗯，现在我们有了我认为非常美味俗气的场景。这是一个俗气大比拼，如果你愿意的话，在简和瑞安之间。
Okay. It's a bonanza. It's fantastic. I can't wait. Oh, my lord. Who knew? Well, now we have what I think is such a deliciously tacky scene. It is a tacky off, if you will, between Jan and Ryan.
哦，太棒了。他说，嗯，你知道，我们可能应该谈谈房间里的大象。我得到了你的工作。她说，没得到我的工作。不是我的薪水，但你会达到的，而且这超级俗气。然后瑞安说，斯克兰顿适合你。简说，我做过的最好的决定。瑞安说，你被解雇了。
Oh, it's so good. He's like, well, you know, we should probably talk about the elephant in the room. I got your job. And she's like, didn't get my job. Not my salary, but you'll get there, and it's super tacky. And then Ryan says, Scranton suits you. And Jan says, best decision I ever made. Ryan says, you were let go.
然后简走了。她看起来很疯狂。她说，你知道吗？喜欢这胡子。永远留着它。并抓了他的胡子。这让他对他的胡子超级不安全。我觉得这太棒了。
And then Jan goes. And she looks maniacal. She says, you know what? Love the beard. Keep it forever. And scratches his beard. And that makes him super insecure about his beard. I thought it was amazing.
太棒了。喜欢这胡子。永远留着它。嗯，你注意到她在这一场景里穿什么了吗？是天鹅绒连体裤，对吧？一件Juicy Couture天鹅绒连体裤，在当时非常流行。是的，它们屁股上写着Juicy。你记得吗？有些有，不是全部，但连帽衫的拉链，因为它是连帽衫和裤子套装，拉链，它有一个小J作为它的，你叫那个东西什么？用拇指和手指握住来拉拉链的拉链头。是的，它叫拉链头吗？我不知道，但我就是这么叫它的。是的，嗯，它是一个J，我记得有一个非常非常流行的东西
Amazing. Love the beard. Keep it forever. Well, did you notice what she's wearing in this scene? It's a velour jumpsuit, right? A juicy couture valour jumpsuit, which were all the rage at this time. Yeah, they said juicy across the butt. Do you remember that? Some of them did, not all of them, but the zipper for the hoodie, because it was a hoodie and pants set, the zipper, it had a little jay as it's, what do you call that thing you're? hold in your thumb and finger to zipper the zipper toggle yeah is it called a zipper toggle i don't know but that's what i call it yeah well it was a j i remember there was this really really popular thing
那就是新娘会在婚礼后的某个时候，在招待会期间换上一件白色Juicy Couture连体裤，她们会让人绣上比如“刚结婚”或者“某某夫人”，她们的新姓氏，我可能在李和我结婚时做过那个。我可能订购了这些白色中的一件，但你没穿它。我在你的招待会上，你从来没出来穿你的慢跑装。嗯，安吉拉，招待会后有一个派对，给所有住在酒店的人，你喜欢在某个时间点离开。我早早看了。
which was that brides would change into a white juicy couture jumpsuit after the wedding some point during the reception and they would get it embroidered with like just married or like misses whatever their new last name is going to be and I might have done that when Lee and I got married I might have ordered one of these white but you didn't wear it I was at your reception you never came out in your your little jogging outfit well Angela there was like an after after party for the reception for everyone who stayed at the hotel you love left at a certain point. I looked early.
你对我有点恼火，但我当时是。我不记得我恼火了。嗯，你只是说，你还不能离开。我说，珍娜，因为我，你知道，我有一个蹒跚学步的孩子。我说，我几点睡觉没关系。她会在同一时间醒来。你在那里吃迷你汉堡和薯条吗？因为那些在午夜出来，我想那可能就是为什么我想让你留下来。
You were annoyed with me a little bit, but I was. I don't remember being annoyed. Well, you just said, and you can't leave yet. And I was like, Jenna, because I, you know, I had a toddler. I was like, it doesn't matter what time I go to bed. She's going to wake up at the same time. Were you there for the miniature burgers and fries? Because those came out at midnight, and I think that might have been why I wanted you to stay.
还有迷你奶昔，因为你知道我喜欢迷你食物。我知道你喜欢。我喜欢当你拿一个普通汉堡，把它缩小到婴儿大小时。我知道。小薯条，小薯条容器，带小吸管的小奶昔。我在10点半左右离开，你就像……什么？你在10点半离开？我有一个年幼的孩子。
There were also miniature shakes because you know I like miniature foods. I know you do. I like it when you take a regular burger and you just shrink it on down to baby size. I know. Little fries, little fry containers, a little shake with a tiny straw. I left around 10.30 and you were like... What? You left at 1030? I had a young kid.
什么都没发生。我有一个年幼的孩子。我得回家。我有一个保姆。我有一个保姆，我说过我11点前会回家。你对我说，你就像，安吉拉，我们要看太阳升起。我不知道你是否了解自己，但偶尔，你决心聚会到日出。是的。我做过几次。而且总是最棒的时光。我做得不多。我把它当作一种特别的款待。是的。我的新婚之夜就是其中之一。凌晨2点半左右，我换上了我的白色天鹅绒，Juicy Couture，定制刺绣，刚结婚。柯克夫人连体裤。
Nothing had happened yet. I had a young kid. I had to get home. I had a sitter. I had a sitter who I said I'd be home by 11. And you said to me, you're like, Angela, we're going to watch the sun come up. And I don't know if you know this about yourself, but every once in a while, you're determined to party until sunrise. Yes. And I've done it a handful of times. And it's always the best time. I don't do it too much. I keep it as like a special treat. Yeah. My wedding night was one of them. And around 2.30 in the morning, I changed into my white velour, juicy couture, custom embroidered, just married. Mrs. Kirk jumpsuit.
嗯，那太可爱了。我想看那张照片。我确实得到了一件可爱的小夹克，我在婚礼结束时穿的，当我离开时，上面写着斯奈德夫人。我记得那个。是的。好的，所以我不知道那是一回事。我甚至不知道你做了那个。哦，天哪。
Well, that's so cute. I want to see a picture of that. I did get a cute little jacket that I wore at the end of my wedding as I left that said Mrs. Snyder on the back. I remember that. Yeah. Okay, so I didn't know that was a thing. And I didn't even know you did it. Oh, my God.
嗯，现在你知道了。现在我知道了。我会给你看照片。是的，我想看。嗯，现在简和迈克尔在吃午饭。简要向迈克尔解释年龄歧视，这太美妙了。太棒了。有一个删除的场景，他们切到那里，迈克尔对德怀特说，我需要你为我找出关于某件事的一切。
Well, now you know. Now I know. I'll show you pictures. Yeah, I want to see. Well, now Jan and Michael are having lunch. And Jan is going to explain ageism to Michael, which is just wonderful. It's so good. And there is a deleted scene that they cut to where Michael says to Dwight, I need you to find out everything you can about something for me.
准备好了吗？它叫年龄歧视。写下来。他说，我不知道那是什么。我需要找出所有细节。我不知道简是在捉弄我还是它是真实存在的东西。但我需要你找出一切。我需要你在一个小时内完成。
Ready? It's called ageism. Write it down. And he's like, I don't know what it is. I need to find all the details. I don't know if Jan is just pranking me or if it's a real thing. But I need you to find it all out. I need you to do it in an hour.
嗯，迈克尔有这句很棒的台词，他说，等等，你是说老年人和年轻人有同样的权利吗？简说，是的。是的。是的，我的。是的。所以来自萨迪S的粉丝捕捉，在这一场景中。嘿，珍娜和安吉拉。我是萨迪。
Well, Michael has this great line where he's like, wait, are you saying that old people have the same rights as young people? And Jan's like, yes. Yeah. Yeah, my. Yeah. So fan catch from Sadie S in this scene. Hi, Jenna and Angela. I'm Sadie.
我14岁，我喜欢《办公室》和你们的播客。谢谢。在15分10秒，当迈克尔和简吃午饭时，看起来迈克尔有一种自制的个人沙拉酱。它在他的桌子上，在一个罐子里，上面有他的脸，一张沙拉的照片，上面写着，“伟大的斯科特”，就像《威胁级别午夜》的制作公司一样。她说，当我注意到这个时，我无法停止笑。谁想到做这个道具的？哦，萨迪，你和我想法一致。我有一个便利贴。15分10秒。我写了沙拉酱。我认为这是《趣味跑》那一集的呼应。但那不是一个删除的场景吗？
I'm 14 and I love the office and your podcast. Thank you. At 15 minutes, 10 seconds, when Michael is having lunch with Jan, it looks like Michael has a personal homemade salad dressing. It is on his desk in a jar with his face on it, a picture of a salad, and it says, Great Scott, just like the production company of Threat Level Midnight. She said, I couldn't stop laughing when I noticed this. Who thought to make this prop? Oh, Sadie, you and I are on the same page. I have a post-it note. 15 minutes, 10 seconds. I put salad dressing. I think it's a callback from the Fun Run episode. But wasn't that a deleted scene?
是的。所以，伙计们，有一个删除的场景，它太棒了。它在《趣味跑》里。迈克尔有一个谈话头，他在谈论他的狂犬病慈善机构。他说，看，它在挣扎。他说，我看起来像什么？保罗·纽曼？然后他说，实际上，那不是一个坏例子，因为人们告诉过我。我看起来像保罗·纽曼。你知道，是眼睛和脸。他说，还有，我自己做沙拉酱。他把纽曼的牧场酱和纽曼的意大利酱混合，在跳蚤市场上亏本出售。如果他把其中一种成分换成Wishbone，他就能盈利，但他不会做。这太不可思议了。所以我认为那是他混合的纽曼牧场酱和纽曼意大利酱。嗯，我喜欢认为，你知道，一旦节目中确立了某件事，
Yes. So, guys, there's a deleted scene and it's so good. It's in Fun Run. Michael has this talking head where he's talking about his charity for rabies. And he says, look, it's struggling. And he says, what do I look like? Paul Newman? And then he goes, actually, that's not a bad example because people have told me. I look like Paul Newman. You know, it's the eyes in the face. And he said, also, I make my own salad dressing. He mixes Newman's Ranch with Newman's Italian and sells it at a flea market for a loss. He could make a profit on it if he changed one of the ingredients to Wishbone, but he won't do it. That is incredible. So I think that is his mixture of Newman's Ranch and Newman's Italian. Well, what I like to think is that, you know, once something has been established on the show,
我们喜欢追踪它。他们在吃沙拉。所以当然，他们会把他的沙拉酱拿出来。我敢打赌，当我们拍摄这一集时，我们还不知道那会从《趣味跑》中剪掉，因为他们还在后期制作中。这就是为什么沙拉酱还在。是的，没错。我完全相信这一点。而且你们，当他们继续谈话和吃沙拉时，我想让你们知道在15分50秒，我认为史蒂夫，作为一个演员，做了一个非常大胆的选择。西兰花？他吃了一块西兰花。我的意思是，那之后你没法说话。场景结束真是太好了。那会花很长时间咀嚼。而且我觉得我看到了一个瞬间。不是迈克尔·斯科特。我看到史蒂夫·卡瑞尔说，哦，该死。我刚把这块西兰花放进嘴里。
we like to track it. They're eating a salad. So of course, they're going to put his salad dressing out. I bet when we film this episode, we didn't yet know that that was going to be cut out from Fun Run because they were still in post-production on it. And that's why the salad dressing remains. Yeah, that's right. I totally believe that. And you guys, as they continue talking and eating their salad, I want you to know at 15 minutes, 50 seconds, I think Steve, as an actor, makes a very bold choice. The broccoli? He eats a piece of broccoli. I mean, you can't talk after that. It's a good thing the scene ended. That would have taken a long time to chew. And I feel like I see a moment. Not Michael Scott. I see Steve Carell go, oh, crap. I just put this piece of broccoli in my mouth.
我想你是对的。我也这么认为。我想你看到了一个后悔的瞬间。嗯，现在安吉拉，有人带着乌黑的头发进入办公室。我们不知道是谁，因为摄像机在办公室里追踪他身后的头部。结果发现是克里德。他想让你知道他只有30岁。我的意思是，嗯，在十一月，他会30岁。他会30岁。是的。
I think you're right. I do too. I think you see a moment of regret. Well, now Angela, someone enters the office with jet black hair. We don't know who because the The camera is tracking him behind his head through the office. And it is revealed to be Creed. He wants you to know he's only 30. I mean, well, in November, he'll be 30. He'll be 30. Yeah.
是的，在十一月。我们收到了很多关于这个的粉丝提问。查莉娅G.，凯瑟琳·奥托，凯利·亨德里克斯，安德里亚V.和朱莉·布朗都问，克里德真的为了这一集染了头发吗？嗯，我们给克里德发了短信。我们确实发了。我们昨天和他有一个愉快的短信串。太搞笑了。
Yeah, in November. We got a lot of fan questions about this. Charlia G., Catherine Otto, Kelly Hendrix, Andrea V. and Julie Brown all asked, did Creed really dye his hair for this episode? Well, we texted Creed. We did. We had a delightful text thread with him yesterday. It was so funny.
我知道。嗯，他说那是一种完全洗掉没问题的植物染料。但他建议我们告诉你们所有人，那是一种永久性染料，导致他所有的头发都掉了，这样他可能可以用这个作为证据来起诉他。金·费里，然后会反诉他诽谤。我说，你把我们的播客变成了法庭惊悚片。我想克里德昨天真的很开心，因为他有一个完整的短信串，他一直在谈论他关于如何染头发的更好故事的不同想法。
I know. Well, he said that it was a vegetable dye that washed out completely no problem. But he suggested that we tell you all that it was a permanent dye that caused all of his hair to fall out so that he could possibly use this as evidence to sue him. Kim Ferry, who would then counter sue him for libel. And I was like, you're turning our podcast into a courtroom thriller. I think Creed yesterday was really tickled because he had a whole text thread with us where he went on and on about his different ideas of like a better story of how they dyed his hair.
是的。他发短信给我们玩得很开心。但事实是，那只是一种洗得掉的植物染料。抱歉，克里德。当然，我们在会议室场景中发现克里德用了打印机里所有的墨水。是的。他把打印机墨水。
Yes. He was having a good time texting us. But the truth was, it was just a washout vegetable dye. Sorry, Creed. And of course, we find out in this conference. conference room scene that Creed used all the ink from the printer. Yeah. He put the printer ink.
有一个删除的场景，珍娜，他有一个镜子，他正在用黑色记号笔填补他错过的点。哦，天哪。我知道。我知道。哦，天哪。嗯，我们可能不得不开始另一个关于那个黑色记号笔删除场景的短信串，因为我需要知道更多。
There is a deleted scene, Jenna, where he has a mirror and he's filling in the spots he missed with a black Sharpie. Oh, my gosh. I know. I know. Oh, my goodness. Well, we might have to start a different text thread with him about that black sharpie deleted scene because I need to know more.
顺便说一下，我们昨天不仅和克里德有一个短信串，只有我们三个，我们还在我们的办公室群组短信串上有很多活动。我们就像都在疯狂地发短信。是的。我有一个单独的会计师短信串。哦，天哪。我们昨天作为演员发短信发疯了。我想我们是。嗯，就像安吉拉说的，每个人都聚集在会议室。瑞安进来做他的黑莓教程，但迈克尔告诉瑞安，抱歉，这仍然是我的办公室。请坐。我不敢相信瑞安会接受这个。我不敢相信。
By the way, we not only had a text thread with Creed yesterday, just the three of us, we also had a lot of activity on our group office text. thread. We were in like all texting each other up a storm. Yes. And I had a separate text thread with just the accountants going. Oh my gosh. We were text happy as a cast yesterday. I guess we were. Well, like Angela said, everyone is gathered in the conference room. Ryan enters to do his Blackberry tutorial, but Michael tells Ryan, I'm sorry, this is still my office. Have a seat. I could not believe that Ryan entertained this. I couldn't believe it.
顺便说一下，昨天我们不仅和克里德有一个只有我们三个人的短信群，我们的办公室群组里也非常活跃。我们所有人都在疯狂地发短信。是的。我还单独和会计们开了一个短信群。天哪。我们昨天作为剧组成员真是发短信发上瘾了。我想确实是这样。嗯，就像安吉拉说的，大家都在会议室里集合了。瑞安进来准备做他的黑莓手机教程，但迈克尔告诉瑞安，抱歉，这还是我的办公室。请坐。我简直不敢相信瑞安竟然会配合他。我真是不敢相信。
Yeah. I mean, as soon as he saw the pictures on the wall. Yeah. He was like, oh, Michael. Here we go. Here we go. It's the lady from Titanic. Mm-hmm.
是啊。我的意思是，他一看到墙上的照片。是的。他就说，哦，迈克尔。我们要开始了。我们要开始了。那是《泰坦尼克号》里的那位女士。嗯。
The Where's the Beef Lady? Yeah. And then the picture from Big where they're dancing on the keyboard. Yes. And then the last one has Ben Kingsley. Yeah. And this is when Pam is like, why did you reuse the old photos? and Michael says because the ink ran out of the printer.
那个“牛肉在哪里”的女士？是的。还有《飞越未来》里他们在键盘上跳舞的照片。是的。最后一张是本·金斯利。是的。这时候帕姆说，你为什么要重复使用旧照片？迈克尔说因为打印机没墨了。
Yeah. And Creed kind of is like, there's like, her, her. But then all of a sudden, someone enters the room, just as Ryan has had enough, in walks, Robert Dunder, one of the founders of Dunder Mifflin. How fantastic was that scene with him? It was so good. Oh, man. I rewatched it like a few times because he's so perfect.
是的。克里德有点像，那是她，她。但突然间，就在瑞安忍无可忍的时候，有人走进了房间，罗伯特·邓德，邓德·米夫林的创始人之一走了进来。和他演对手戏感觉怎么样？太棒了。哦，天哪。我重看了好几次，因为他太完美了。
His delivery is spot on. Well, Robert Dunder was played by this actor named John Engel. And this is the only episode that Robert Dunder appears in. But John Engel starred on General Hospital. He played Patriarch Edward Quartermain from 1993 to 2012. He did 485 episodes of General Hospital. Wow. He also did a ton of other television work.
他的台词功底非常到位。嗯，罗伯特·邓德是由一位名叫约翰·恩格尔的演员扮演的。这是罗伯特·邓德出现的唯一一集。但约翰·恩格尔曾主演过《综合医院》。他从1993年到2012年饰演族长爱德华·夸特梅因。他出演了485集《综合医院》。哇。他还参与了大量的其他电视工作。
He was also an acting teacher at Beverly Hills High School from 1964 to 1985 and listened to who he taught while he was a teacher there. He taught Nicholas Cage, Albert Brooks, Swozy Kurtz, David Schwimmer, and Jonathan Silverman, among others. He was also an active volunteer for Habitat for Humanity. He had five daughters, and he passed away in 2012. Well, we were so fortunate to have him. He was such a seasoned actor and so delightful, and I love the scene. He goes on this very, very long, meandering story, but the way he connects it all is so real and organic. And you guys, we have been there.
他还是比佛利山庄高中的表演老师，从1964年到1985年，听听他在那里教过谁。他教过尼古拉斯·凯奇、阿尔伯特·布鲁克斯、斯沃西·库尔茨、大卫·休默和乔纳森·西尔弗曼等人。他还是“仁人家园”的积极志愿者。他有五个女儿，于2012年去世。嗯，我们很幸运能有他。他是一位经验丰富的演员，非常令人愉快，我喜欢那个场景。他讲了一个非常非常漫长、蜿蜒曲折的故事，但他把这一切联系起来的方式非常真实和自然。伙计们，我们都经历过这种情况。
We have all been there at that. you know, family gathering where someone gets up to talk and you're like, what do we, what are we talking about? Yeah, you ask some innocent question like, oh my gosh, where'd you get your sweater? And they're like, well, it was three years ago. And it was raining that day. I remember. I remember because I just got my hair done and they gave me a plastic net to put over it. Yes. And my friend Cynthia called. And she said, well, you know, Cynthia, she had lived. abroad and when she came back she divorced and married that younger guy well she did but first remember she had that period of time where she went on that sex sabbatical she did that's right about
我们都经历过那种家庭聚会，有人站起来说话，你会想，我们在说什么？是的，你问了一些无辜的问题，比如，哦天哪，你的毛衣是在哪买的？他们会说，嗯，那是三年前了。那天还在下雨。我记得。我记得是因为我刚做完头发，他们给了我一个塑料网罩在上面。是的。我朋友辛西娅打了电话。她说，嗯，你知道，辛西娅，她住在国外，回来后她离婚了，嫁给了那个年轻的家伙，嗯，她确实嫁了，但首先记得她有一段时间去休了性休假吗？她确实那样做了，那是关于
when she got that mole removed do you remember her dermatologist he was such a nice guy of course tall guy tall and had an accent yeah but i could never figure out where he was from Yeah. He made a very good dip. And you're like, what? You're like, where's the sweater from? Where's the sweater? What did we just? Jen and I just completely improvised this random conversation. But you guys know you've been in this moment. Yeah. That was Robert Dunder. And so Michael throws him out. Wait, can we also, sorry, this is hopping around. Can we also talk about how Michael introduces Robert to everyone? please. He says, who is this worthless bag of bones? That's his introduction to the founder of the company. Well, we also had a fan question query from Aaron Kearney, who says, Robert Dunder mentions Robert Mifflin's wife and her husband, Jerry Truppiano, a South Jersey guy who was tall.
她切除那个痣的时候，你还记得她的皮肤科医生吗？他是个很好的人，当然，个子很高，还有口音。是的，但我从来没弄明白他是哪里人。是的。他做的蘸酱很好吃。你会想，什么？你会想，毛衣是哪来的？毛衣在哪？我们刚才说了什么？珍和我就完全即兴发挥了这段随机的对话。但你们知道，你们也经历过这种时刻。是的。那是罗伯特·邓德。所以迈克尔把他赶走了。等等，我们能，抱歉，这有点跳跃。我们能谈谈迈克尔是如何向大家介绍罗伯特的吗？拜托。他说，这个毫无价值的骨头架子是谁？这是他对公司创始人的介绍。嗯，我们还收到了亚伦·卡尼的一个粉丝提问，他说，罗伯特·邓德提到了罗伯特·米夫林的妻子和她的丈夫杰瑞·特鲁皮亚诺，一个来自南泽西的高个子男人。
My question is, was this? a reference to Jerry Truppiano, the longtime Red Sox broadcaster. I thought it might be because so many of the cast members and writers were Boston area folks. Well, I believe it to be true because Mike Scher, who wrote this episode, is a huge baseball fan. Yeah. And I 100% think that's true. I think that's a good catch. Yeah. Good catch. Yeah, he's snuck in a baseball player in there. Well, as everyone is leaving the conference room, Ryan tells Michael, this day was a wash. Michael needs to embrace the new technology as the way of the future. He really needs to get behind this new way of doing things. And Michael's like, no, you know what? I'm going to prove you
我的问题是，这是对长期担任红袜队播音员的杰瑞·特鲁皮亚诺的引用吗？我以为可能是，因为很多演员和编剧都是波士顿地区的人。嗯，我相信这是真的，因为写这一集的迈克·舒尔是个超级棒球迷。是的，我百分之百认为这是真的。我认为这是一个很好的发现。是的。好发现。是的，他把一个棒球运动员塞进去了。嗯，当每个人都离开会议室时，瑞安告诉迈克尔，这一天白费了。迈克尔需要拥抱新技术作为未来的方式。他真的需要支持这种新的做事方式。迈克尔说，不，你知道吗？我要证明你是
wrong. That the old way is the best way. I'm going to prove you wrong. We don't know what that's going to be. But Michael says that. And Jenna, there is a deleted scene. I have to tell you, there's another department that's very stressed out about this, because Ryan has a moment with the accountants where he shows them the new program they're going to use online for all of the accounting of Dunder Mifflin. And it's basically going to make them obsolete. Wow. So people are freaking out about this, this new technology that Dunder Mifflin is going to be using. Well, we're going to get more of Michael's reaction to all of this in the next episode. We end this episode, though, with Angela and Dwight's dinner date.
错的。旧方法才是最好的方法。我要证明你是错的。我们不知道那会是什么。但迈克尔是这么说的。珍娜，有一个删减片段。我必须告诉你，还有另一个部门对此感到非常紧张，因为瑞安和会计们有一个时刻，他向他们展示了他们将在线用于邓德·米夫林所有会计工作的新程序。这基本上会让他们变得过时。哇。所以人们对邓德·米夫林将要使用的这项新技术感到恐慌。嗯，我们将在下一集中看到迈克尔对此的所有反应。不过，我们以安吉拉和德怀特的晚餐约会结束了这一集。
Yes. Well, lady, I have some location trivia. I know you love a good location story. I do, and I will tell you, Ivy Burke will be very excited to hear what you have to say, because Ivy would like to know where you filmed the Dwight and Angela dinner. We filmed it in the most beautiful. neighborhood. It's called the Malibu Lake Mountain Club. It's a private community, so much so that there are no signs off the freeway for it. Wow. Yeah, it's like they don't want to be found. It's really,
是的。嗯，女士，我有一些外景花絮。我知道你喜欢好的外景故事。我喜欢，我会告诉你，艾薇·伯克会很高兴听到你要说的话，因为艾薇想知道你们在哪里拍摄了德怀特和安吉拉的晚餐。我们在一个最美丽的社区拍摄的。它叫马里布湖山俱乐部。这是一个私人社区，以至于高速公路上没有它的标志。哇。是的，就像他们不想被找到一样。它真的，
really beautiful. This neighborhood was created in 1924. It was just like a valley, and they made a lake, a man-made lake, and the members really wanted to keep it a secret. So they removed the highway signs that gave directions to the lake, hoping to hide it from tourists. In 1936, they built a clubhouse with a ballroom and a large patio, and it had a speakeasy poker room and a mural of the original members, and only members can use the lake and the swimming pool and the tennis court. So it's this little private community. Ronald Reagan was the honorary mayor, and technically, that's the first political office he ever held. Wow. Mm-hmm. Now, let me ask you a question. Did you film at this location because this lake is going to feature
非常漂亮。这个社区建于1924年。它就像一个山谷，他们造了一个湖，一个人造湖，成员们真的想保密。所以他们移除了指引湖方向的高速公路标志，希望能避开游客。1936年，他们建了一个带舞厅和大露台的会所，里面有地下酒吧扑克室和原始成员的壁画，只有成员才能使用湖泊、游泳池和网球场。所以这是一个小小的私人社区。罗纳德·里根是名誉市长，从技术上讲，这是他担任的第一个政治职务。哇。嗯。现在，让我问你一个问题。你们在这个地点拍摄是因为这个湖将在下一集中有
prominently in the next episode? Ding, ding, ding, ding, ding. Okay, so we had this location for one day. Dwight and Angela filmed their dinner date in the lodge at Malibu Lake, their restaurant. And then we will see what happens to Michael and Dwight with the lake in the next episode. But that was all the same day. We filmed our scene at night. So Jenna, I had a late call time. Oh. There was this huge moon. And after we did the scene, I walked out on this floating dock and just watched the moon for a minute. And it was just like, you know, one of those magical nights on set where you're like, this feels so cool, because it's really a beautiful little area. And Steve Correll has made their official website. Ready for this? It says, just a few of the famous faces that have shot here.
重要的戏份吗？叮，叮，叮，叮，叮。好吧，所以我们有一天的时间在这个地点拍摄。德怀特和安吉拉在马里布湖的旅馆里拍摄了他们的晚餐约会，那是他们的餐厅。然后我们将在下一集中看到迈克尔和德怀特在湖边发生了什么。但这都是同一天。我们在晚上拍摄了我们的场景。所以珍娜，我有一个很晚的通告时间。哦。当时有个月亮很大。在我们拍完那个场景后，我走到那个浮动码头上，盯着月亮看了一会儿。这就像，你知道，片场那些神奇的夜晚之一，你会觉得，这感觉太酷了，因为它确实是一个非常美丽的小区域。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔制作了他们的官方网站。准备好了吗？上面写着，在这里拍摄过的一些名人面孔。
Charlie Chaplin, W.C. Fields, Diane Lane, Lloyd Bridges, Lucille Ball, Steve Carell, Betty Davis, Henry Fonda. It goes on and on, but Steve Carell made the list. I love that. I know, right? Really fun. But this scene between Rain and I, I just loved doing it. We took the scene apart because Dwight is hoping that it's one thing. Angel is trying for it to be a reconciliation. And then she just can't do it. Yeah. And they wanted me to be able to show that emotion in my face that I was trying. And then I just couldn't get past it. I couldn't get past it. And it's got a couplet of dialogue that I love. It's when Angela says, I heard a joke today. And Dwight says, oh, that's funny. And Angela says, yes, it was. Yeah. Well, this scene is just beautiful. Well, this scene is just beautiful. It's beautiful for all the reasons you said. It's funny, but then it breaks your heart because your performance, Angela, we really see your character's heart breaking in this moment. And it's just real.
查理·卓别林、W.C.菲尔兹、黛安·莲恩、劳埃德·布里奇斯、露西尔·鲍尔、史蒂夫·卡瑞尔、贝蒂·戴维斯、亨利·方达。名单还在继续，但史蒂夫·卡瑞尔上了榜。我喜欢这个。我知道，对吧？真的很有趣。但我和雷恩之间的这场戏，我真的很喜欢拍。我们拆解了这场戏，因为德怀特希望这是一回事。安吉拉试图让它成为一次和解。然后她就是做不到。是的。他们希望我能在脸上表现出那种我正在努力的情绪。然后我就是无法释怀。我无法释怀。它有一句我喜欢的台词。那是安吉拉说，我今天听了一个笑话。德怀特说，哦，那很有趣。安吉拉说，是的，确实很有趣。嗯，这个场景太美了。嗯，这个场景太美了。它因为你说的所有原因而美丽。它很有趣，但随后它让你心碎，因为你的表演，安吉拉，我们真的看到了你的角色在这一刻心碎了。而且它是真实的。
Like you aren't playing it for comedy. It's just real. And these are the moments of the office that I'm so proud of as a television comedy that we took these moments to get really real. I loved it. Thanks. I loved it. Thanks. I really enjoyed the storyline. I loved Dwight and Angela being together, and I loved when they were at odds. It was equally fun to play. Yeah. It's such a good dynamic. Well, you know, Jenna, one of the things that got me so tickled was that during this time, the Dwight Angela relationship was compared by a TV journalist to Hot Lips Hulahan and Frank from MASH. And that was a show. I grew up watching. with my dad. And I just was so tickled by that. Oh, that's perfect. And that was Dunder Mifflin Infinity part one. Yes. And I would like to say thank you to Joya Balfour for giving us the digital media inside info. And you can check out her website at joia balfour.com for some fun stuff that they were doing at NBC.com. Well, when we pick up this storyline, we're going to have some lovely gift
就像你不是为了喜剧而演。它是真实的。这些是《办公室》中我作为一部电视喜剧感到非常自豪的时刻，我们利用这些时刻变得非常真实。我喜欢它。谢谢。我喜欢它。谢谢。我真的很喜欢这个故事情节。我喜欢德怀特和安吉拉在一起，我也喜欢他们不和的时候。演起来同样有趣。是的。这是一种很好的动态。嗯，你知道，珍娜，让我感到非常高兴的一件事是，在这段时间里，德怀特和安吉拉的关系被一位电视记者比作《陆军野战医院》中的“热唇”胡拉汉和弗兰克。那是我和爸爸一起长大的节目。我对此感到非常高兴。哦，那太完美了。那是《邓德·米夫林无限》第一部分。是的。我想感谢乔亚·巴尔福为我们提供数字媒体内幕信息。你可以访问她的网站 joia balfour.com，了解他们在 NBC.com 上做的一些有趣的事情。嗯，当我们继续这个故事情节时，我们将会有一些可爱的礼品
baskets and a huge stunt, especially for our show. I was so impressed. I can't wait to talk about it. All right, you guys, have a great week. We'll see you next time. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkens. and our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz.
篮子和一个巨大的特技，特别是为了我们的节目。我印象非常深刻。我迫不及待想谈谈它。好了，伙计们，祝你们度过愉快的一周。我们下次见。再见。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。这一集最初是与 Earwolf 合作创作的。《办公室女士》是 Odyssey 的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰肯斯。我们的音频工程师和副制片人是莫莉·纽金特。Odyssey 的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. Okay, only 10 more presents to wrap. You're almost at the finish line. But first? There, the last one. Enjoy a Coca-Cola for a pause that refreshes. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。好了，只剩下10个礼物要包了。你快到终点线了。但首先？在那，最后一个。享受可口可乐，享受片刻清爽。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。